ओके
सो आई थिंक आई एम लाइव नाउ अ लेट मी लेट
मी चेक वंस प्लीज लेट मी नो गाइस नमस्ते
टू एवरीबॉडी सभी लोग एक बार बता दीजिए इफ
आई एम लाइव
एक बार सभी लोग जल्दी-जल्दी फटाफट बताइए
फटाफट फटाफट फटाफट विदाउट एनी डिले लेट मी
नो इफ आई एम ऑडिबल एंड विज़िबल क्लियरली सब
कुछ क्लियर
एकदम क्रिस्टल क्लियर है। गुड इवनिंग।
नमस्ते। नमस्ते टू एवरीबॉडी। गुड इवनिंग।
मैं भी चेक कर लेता हूं क्योंकि मैं जब तक
चेक नहीं कर पाता हूं अपने साइड से तब तक
मुझे
सेटिस्फेक्शन नहीं मिलती है कि आई एम
टोटली लाइव।
ओके। सो या एवरीथिंग इज गुड।
ओके।
ओके चलिए आज की सेशन स्टार्ट तो करेंगे बट
सबसे पहले मैं बोलना चाहता हूं कि आप
लोगों में से काफी लोग कमेंट्स नहीं कर
रहे हैं प्रीवियस वीडियोस पे जो भी
क्लासेस हो रही हैं ये गलत बात है। यू हैव
टू कमेंट ऑन वीडियोस। राइट? आप कमेंट नहीं
करेंगे फिर ये गलत बात है। आपको एटलीस्ट
100 प्लस कमेंट्स तो करने ही हैं। जैसा कि
अ मैंने आपको पहले भी बोला था। तो प्लीज
आप हर वीडियो को जब भी कोई क्लास कंप्लीट
हो जाए उसको जब वापस से आप देख लेते हैं
तो उस पे जाके कमेंट कर दिया कीजिएगा कि
कंप्लीटेड अपने नाम के साथ। ठीक है? दैट्स
इट। दैट्स व्हाट एक्चुअली अ वी वांट नथिंग
एल्स। इतना बस कर देंगे। दैट्स इट। काफी
है इतना।
ओके।
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़][अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
गुड इवनिंग। नमस्ते। नमस्ते।
कोई बात नहीं। चलो वो भी कवर हो जाएगा।
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
वो भी कवर हो जाएगा यार। वो भी कवर हो
जाएगा। नो इशूज़।
ओके चलिए लेट मी अ
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़][अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
एक बार मैं भी इधर कर लेता हूं। ओके ट ट
ओके नमस्ते नमस्ते। नमस्ते एवरीबॉडी। गुड
इवनिंग। सभी को एक बार आ जाने देते हैं
फटाफट। लेट एवरीबॉडी
जॉइन फर्स्ट देन वी विल बी स्टार्टिंग
राइट
हम
आप लोगों में से किसको कौन सी कोल्ड
ड्रिंक पसंद है
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़][गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़]
फैंटा मिररिंडा
coca कोला थम्स अप लिमका कौन कौन सी
ओके नमस्ते नमस्ते सभी को
अ गुड इवनिंग गुड इवनिंग एवरीबॉडी अ वेरी
वेरी गुड इवनिंग एंड नमस्ते टू एवरीबॉडी
सो सभी लोग एक बार आ जाते हैं फिर वी विल
बी स्टार्टिंग अभी तक सभी जॉइ नहीं हुए
हैं तो लेट एवरीबडी जॉइ फर्स्ट एंड देन वी
विल बी स्टार्टिंग
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
यस आई लव लिमका
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके आज की क्लास तो स्टार्ट करेंगे। आज की
क्लास बहुत इंटरेस्टिंग होने वाली है। आज
पावर शेल के बारे में हम जानने वाले हैं।
पावर शेल के बारे में पढ़ने वाले हैं। एंड
उससे पहले मैं आपसे एक रिक्वेस्ट करूंगा
कि प्लीज इट्स अ रिक्वेस्ट कि आप सभी जब
भी लाइव सेशन को ज्वाइन करते हैं तो उसको
एक तो लाइक ठोक दिया करो। वो तो ठीक है।
अच्छा होता है। और दूसरी चीज कि प्लीज आप
सभी कमेंट्स किया कीजिए। जब भी कोई जब आप
ये लाइव सेशन एंड हो जाती है, जब आप
वीडियो रिकॉर्डेड देखते हैं वापस से तो आप
कमेंट किया कीजिए। 100 प्लस कमेंट कर दिया
कीजिए। इट विल बी गुड फॉर अस। ठीक है? और
आज मैं लेकर बैठा हूं आप लोगों को थोड़ी
सी आपको लालच तो आएगी बट कोई बात नहीं
चलेगा वि माय ओन होममेड कोल्ड कॉफी
इट्स
टेस्टियर बहुत टेस्टी है। बहुत शानदार है।
आप [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] सबों के लिए
भी है। यू गाइस कैन आल्सो हैव अ सिप। थैंक
यू वेरी मच। ऑफर कर लिया मैंने।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके। चलिए।
ठीक है। सो बिफोर स्टार्ट लेट्स अगेन मैं
आपको एक चीज बता देता हूं जो हमेशा मैं
बताता हूं। सबसे पहला आपका काम होता है जब
भी आप वीडियो देखें ये वाली।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] तो
डिफ्रॉनिक्स एकडमी YouTube चैनल पे आपको आ
जाना है। किसी भी लाइव एसओसी क्लासेस के
लाइव सेक्शन में चले जाना है। किसी भी
प्रीवियस लाइव सेशन में।
ओके? एंड यहां पे
[खांसने की आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
डिस्क्रिप्शन को एक्सपेंड जब करेंगे आप तो
यहां पे पहला और दूसरा दो लिंक्स मिलेंगे
WhatsApp के। एक आपका WhatsApp चैनल का
लिंक मिलेगा डिफॉिश एकडमी। आप इसको जाके
फॉलो जरूर कर लीजिएगा। लगभग 12,000 से भी
ज्यादा लोग वहां से हमसे जुड़े हुए हैं।
जितनी भी अपडेट्स जो भी ओवरऑल कंप्लीट
अपडेट्स एंड सबसे पहले जो अपडेट आती है वो
इसी चैनल पे आती है। तो इसको फॉलो तो जरूर
करना है आपको। दूसरा है एसओसी से
रिगार्डिंग एक ग्रुप जो कि एसओसी के लिए
स्पेशलिस्ट आपके लिए जो एसओसी के स्पेशल
ग्रुप है वो है। यहां आप जॉइ कर लेना जो
भी एसओसी रिलेटेड लाइक रिसोर्सेज हैं,
पीपीटीस हैं सब आपको यहां पे ही मिलेंगी।
तो ये काम आप दोनों कर लीजिएगा। देन
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] ये मेरी
Lindin प्रोफाइल है। आप इस पे मुझसे आके
कनेक्ट हो सकते हैं। फॉलो कर सकते हैं।
मेरे वर्क को फॉलो कर सकते हैं। मुझसे
इंटरेक्ट कर सकते हैं। दिस इज़ द Lindin
प्रोफाइल। एंड यहीं पे आप जब Lindin पे
डिफ़्रॉनिक्स सर्च करेंगे तो यू विल गेट द
कंपनी हमारी डिफ्रॉनिक्स के Lindin पेज
जहां पर लगभग 22,000 लोग हमसे जुड़े हैं।
आप इसको भी आके यहां पर फॉलो कर सकते हैं।
कंपनी के रिगार्डिंग जो भी आपको अपडेट्स
जो भी हम नया कुछ करने जा रहे हैं। कुछ नई
अपडेट्स एंड इनेशन एंड व्हाटएवर सब कुछ
आपको इस पे मिलेगा। ये Lindin लाइक
Instagram की प्रोफाइल है। मेरी ये मेरी
प्राइवेट पर्सनल प्रोफाइल है। आप इस पे
मुझसे कनेक्ट हो के मुझे फॉलो अप कर सकते
हैं। यू कैन गेट अलोंग वि मी एंड यू कैन
नो मी एंड ऑल ऑल। यहां पे फिर डिफ़्रॉनिक्स
एकडमी प्रोफाइल है ये। यह हमारी कंपनी की
प्रोफाइल है। आप इस पे भी आके हमें फॉलो
कर सकते हैं। लाइक फॉर इनफेशन रील
कंटेंट्स एंड एक्सट्रा एक्सट्रा। दिस इज़ द
Twitter हैंडल एक्स एक्स हैंडल। आई वुड से
एक्स पेज यू कैन
लाइक कम हियर एंड यू कैन जस्ट फॉलो हियर
आल्सो। एंड दिस इज़ आवर वेबसाइट जहां पे आप
हमारे लग जो भी अपडेट्स हैं वेबसाइट पे आप
वेबसाइट के थ्रू भी ले सकते हैं। एकडमी
वाले पे जाके हमारे कोर्सर्सेस जो हैं
उसको एक्सप्लोर कर सकते हैं। एंड ये हमारा
WhatsApp नंबर है। आप इस पे हमसे किसी भी
तरह की क्वेरीज क्वेश्चंस कर सकते हैं।
राइट? तो ये काम आपको पहले कर लेना है।
एंड देन वी विल बी मूविंग फॉरवर्ड। आज की
टॉपिक काफी ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट एंड काफी
इंटरेस्टिंग टॉपिक भी है। तो आपको मजा आने
वाला है थ्रूउ द सेशन। आप प्लीज कंटिन्यू
रहिए। एंड इसी तरह लाइव सेशन में आते रहिए
तो आपको मजा आता रहेगा। तो हां तो
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] बिफोर वी
स्टार्ट द टॉपिक फर्स्ट ऑफ ऑल आई वुड लाइक
टू आस्क यू एवरीबॉडी आप में से जितने लोग
भी यहां पे प्रेजेंट हैं आपके कितने
क्लासेस अभी तक आपने लाइव वाली कर ली हैं
कितनी अभी तक कर ली है लाइक क्लास 20 तक
हैं 21 तक आपने मतलब आज 20 तक आपने कर ली
है या 18 पे हैं 10थ पे हैं फिफ्थ पे हैं
कितने पे हैं प्लीज एवरीवन लेट मी नो गुड
इवनिंग गुड इवनिंग आई एम गुड आई एम गुड
प्लीज एवरीवन लेट मी नो
क्लास
ठीक है।
ओके।
ठीक है। बहुत सारे लोगों ने
ओके। सो मतलब मतलब कुछ लोग पीछे हैं अभी
चल रहे हैं। कुछ लोग लाइक नॉट एवरीवन कुछ
लोग पीछे चल रहे हैं। एंड कई लोग जो हैं
वो साथ में भी चल रहे हैं जो अभी यहां पे
प्रेजेंट हैं। एंड कई लोगों ने लाइक 15 के
अंदर में क्लासेस करी हैं। कुछ लोगों ने
15 के ऊपर 20 तक भी कर ली है। कुछ लोग
थोड़ा और भी पहले चल रहे हैं। लाइक कि 10थ
10 क्लासेस के भी अंदर कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं
है। बट आई वुड सजेस्ट एवरीबॉडी टू प्लीज
प्लीज इंक्रीस योर पेस। आप थोड़ी सी अपनी
पेस को इंक्रीस कर दीजिए एंड उसके बाद आप
जल्दी-जल्दी इसको कवर कर लीजिए क्योंकि
अभी अपना Windows वाला Windows ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम की जो क्लासेस हैं वो चल रही हैं।
इसके बाद Linux वाली हमारी जो स्टार्ट
होंगी एंड लinक्स के बाद जस्ट आपका एसओसी
का जो डेमोंस्ट्रेशन प्रैक्टिकल लैब्स एंड
बाकी चीजें जो हैं वो स्टार्ट हो जाएंगी
एंड उसके बाद आपकी एसओसी की सीरीज ये
कंप्लीट हो जानी है।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] तो आपकी
एसओसी की सीरीज मोस्ट प्रोबेबबली मतलब मैं
मान के चलता हूं कि जून एंड एंड तक मैं
कोशिश कर रहा हूं कि कंप्लीट इसको कर दी
जाए। मैं कोशिश कर रहा हूं फिर इसको आप
दिमाग में वो लेके मत कर लीजिएगा कि कि सर
आपने जून तक कंप्लीट नहीं। मैं जून तक
पूरी ट्राई कर रहा हूं। अपनी तरफ से बेस्ट
दूंगा कि आपकी जून तक ये क्लासेस कंप्लीट
हो जाए। एंड आप अगर आप थर्ड ईयर, फाइनल
ईयर वगैरह में भी हैं तो आप अपने आप के
लिए प्रिपेयर करने लगे। एंड जॉब वगैरह के
लिए इंटरव्यूज के लिए आप प्रिपेयर होने
लगे एंड देन इंटरव्यू सेशंस जो है वो भी
कंडक्ट करेंगे एंड देखेंगे कि किस तरीके
से इंटरव्यूज वगैरह में क्वेश्चंस होते
हैं। एवरीथिंग वी विल बी डूइंग। ठीक है?
सो आई एम ट्राइंग माय बेस्ट। चलिए
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] सर आपके जैसा
कोई नहीं है इंडिया में जो इतना फ्री में
सिखाता है। महादेव ब्लेस यू सर। भगवान
आपको
बहुत आगे देखना चाहता हूं। थैंक यू वेरी
मच ब्रदर फॉर योर काइंड विशेस एंड सच अ
गुड गुड विशे
आई एम देयर फॉर यू गाइस एवरीबडी फॉर मैं
आपके लिए हमेशा से हूं मैं एक बात क्लियर
आपको हमेशा बोलता आया हूं फिर भी बोल रहा
हूं लाइक डिफ्रॉनिक्स इज ऑलवेज देयर एंड
मैं हमेशा उधर हूं। मैं अभी बहुत कुछ और
प्लान कर रहा हूं आने वाले टाइम में एंड
जो आपको एक साइबर
वरियर बना के रखेगी एंड या तो फ्री होगा
या तो बहुत अफोर्डेबल
फी में कर सकते हैं। अभी हम कुछ और भी
चीजें लाने वाले हैं जो काफी काफी
अफोर्डेबल होने वाला है एंड काफी कम हम
उसकी फी रखने वाले हैं। लाइक कि कोई भी
बंदा जो मतलब करना चाहता है, सीखना चाहता
है वो अपने पॉकेट मनी से उस चीज को सीख
सकता है। हम ऐसी चीजें ला रहे हैं कि अगर
कोई कॉलेज में है या स्कूल में भी है तो
उसको महीने का अगर ₹500,000 पॉकेट मनी
मिलती है। इतना तो ₹500,000 तो खर्च कर ही
देते हैं। आज के टाइम में ₹5,000 आप महीने
का खत्म कर देते हैं, खर्च कर देते हैं।
तो, उस रेंज में भी आप कुछ ऐसा सीख सके जो
आपकी साइबर सिक्योरिटी की जर्नी या तो
स्टार्ट कर दे या तो आपको एक लेवल तक ले
जाके रखें। एंड देन वहां से फिर आप आगे और
बढ़ना शुरू कर दीजिए। तो देयर आर मल्टीपल
थिंग्स दैट वी विल बी लॉन्चिंग वेरी सून।
एंड आप सबको पता ही होगा कि
आल्सो [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] लाइक वी
आर गोइंग टू हिट 50000्राइबर मार्क। सो
इट्स इट्स अ ग्रेट अचीवमेंट
एंड [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ऑल बिकॉज़ ऑफ़ यू यू गाइस। सो थैंक यू वेरी
मच। चलिए
ओके
लेट्स स्टार्ट द सेशन राइट।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके आज एसओसी क्लास वन जो है इसमें हम
इंटरेस्टिंग आज टॉपिक करने वाले हैं। ठीक
है? आज की टॉपिक क्योंकि आज हम पढ़ने वाले
हैं Windows पावर शेल के बारे में। ठीक
है? Windows पावर शेल देखने में सुनने में
हो सकता है आपको नॉर्मल लगता हो। एक कमांड
लाइन इंटरफ़ेस लगता हो। जैसे सीएमडी है
Windows में देखो, Windows में CMD ऑलरेडी
था। राइट? कमांड प्र्प्ट जिसको आप बोलते
हैं व्हाटएवर ऑलरेडी था। तो पावर शेल को
क्यों लाया गया? व्हाई पावर शेल इज ब्रॉट
अप? पहली बात। दूसरी चीज कि क्या दोनों
सेम है? तीसरी चीज कि पावर शेल और सीएमडी
दोनों में से कौन सा यूज़ करना चाहिए? एंड
पावर शेल सीएमडी से सब क्यों बहुत ज्यादा
पावरफुल चीज है? यह भी आज आपको समझ में आ
जाएगा। एंड एथिकल हैकिंग की बात करें,
एसओसी की बात करें या किसी भी तरह के
फॉरेंसिक्स इन्वेस्टिगेशन की बात करें। हम
पावर शेल का यूज़ हर जगह करते हैं। पावर
शेल इज़ वन ऑफ़ द मोस्ट बैड ऐश थिंग इन द
Windows इकोसिस्टम। यह Windows का पावर
हाउस है। इसको आप पावर शेल मत बोलो। यू
कैन टेल इट। यू कैन से इट एज Windows पावर
हाउस। कमांड लाइन इंटरफ़ेस।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
देखिए पावर शेल की तरफ बढ़ते हैं। उसके
पहले मैं आपको दिखाऊं कि पावर शेल अगर
आपको पावर शेल अगर ओपन करना है सिंपल सा
फंडा है। पावर शेल सर्च कर लो आप। आपको
यहां पे पावर शेल मिल जाएंगे। पावर शेल से
वर्जन भी मिल जाएगा यहां पे। एंड बेसिकली
नॉर्मल पावर शेल्स जो है वो भी आपको यहां
पे इसके [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] मिल
जाएंगे। तो कोई सा भी आप पावर शेल ओपन कर
सकते हो। कोई Windows पावर शेल नॉर्मल
पावर शेल आप ओपन करोगे।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] कुछ इस तरीके से
आपका पावर शेल ओपन हो जाएगा। राइट? उसी
तरीके से यहां पे आप कोई सा भी ओपन कर
सकते हैं। पावर शेल 7 है। मैं इसको अगर
ओपन करता हूं। ये भी आपका इस तरीके से कुछ
इस तरीके से ओपन हो जाएगा। यहां पे कुछ
नया अपडेट है। तो यह बता रहे हैं। आप
अपडेट वगैरह कर सकते हैं। उसी तरीके से आप
पावर शेल ऐसे सर्च करो एंड पावर शेलel
Windows power शेल आईएससी जो है आप उसको
भी स्टार्ट कर सकते हैं। लाइक काइंड ऑफ़
कुछ एक इंटरफ़ेस टाइप थिंग जैसे है। इस
तरीके से जहां पे आपको एक कमांड हेल्प
मेन्यू के साथ मिल जाएगी। कुछ इस तरीके
का। तो आईएससी वाला जो मॉडल है वो भी आप
ओपन कर सकते हैं। जहां पे बेसिकली आपको
यहां पे सीएमडी लेट्स काफी सारे मिल
जाएंगे। कमांड लेट्स जिसको बोलते हैं
कमांड्स जिसको बेसिकली बोल लो कमांड्स बोल
लो या कमांड सीएमडी लेट्स इनको बोला जाता
है राइट साइड में। तो ये सारे सीएमडी
लेट्स जो है आपको यहां पे मिल जाने हैं।
जैसे ही सीएमडी लेट्स आप ओपन करोगे यहां
पे तो यहां पे सारे सीएमडी के कमांड्स जो
इसके एसोसिएटेड है वो लिस्ट मिल जाएगी।
एंड यहां पे आप इसके अ जो डिस्क्रिप्शंस
है वो डिस्क्रिप्शन देख सकते हो। सो डिटेल
करके आप अदर फदर इन थिंग्स जो है उसको
एक्सप्लोर कर सकते हो। सो देयर आर मल्टीपल
थिंग्स। आप यहां पे लाइक कमांड्स को रन कर
सकते हो। मैं यहां पे इसकी साइज वगैरह भी
थोड़ी बढ़ा सकते हो आप कंट्रोल शिफ्ट प्लस
से एंड यू कैन स्टार्ट यूजिंग पावर शेल।
तो देयर आर मल्टीपल थिंग्स। नाउ
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़][खांसने की आवाज़]
आज जो हम पार्शियल के बारे में पढ़ने वाले
हैं, वह एसओसी से फ़मिलियर चीज़ करने वाले
हैं। एसओसी के रिगार्डिंग हम करने वाले
हैं। क्योंकि बीइंग
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] एन एसओसी एल1
बीइंग एन एसओसी एनालिस्ट आपके लिए पावर
शेल बहुत ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट एक यूटिलिटी
होने वाला है। क्योंकि अटैकर्स पावर शेल
का यूज़ करके डिफरेंट टाइप ऑफ अटैक्स करते
हैं। एंड फाइलेस मैल्वस जो है वन ऑफ़ द अह
डेंजरस अटैक वह पावर शेल के थ्रू की जाती
है जिसको डिटेक्ट करना भी थोड़ा मुश्किल
होता है। एंड अगर आपको अच्छे से नॉलेज
नहीं है इस चीज के बारे में तो फिर आपके
लिए थोड़ी सी प्रॉब्लमेटिक हो सकती है। सो
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
सबसे पहले व्हाट इज पावर शेल? तो पावर शेल
इज़ Microsoft कमांड लाइन शेल प्लस
स्क्रिप्टिंग लैंग्वेज। ठीक है? यह
Microsoft का एक कमांड लाइन शेल है। एंड
एक स्क्रिप्टिंग लैंग्वेज यू कैन आल्सो
से। यह दोनों मिला के बनाया गया है पावर
शेल को। बेसिकली पावर शेल को बनाया गया है
सिस्टम एडमिनिस्ट्रेशन के लिए, ऑटोमेशन जो
टास्क हैं उसके लिए एंड रिमोट मैनेजमेंट
के लिए। मतलब सिस्टम एडमिनिस्ट्रेशन का
जितना भी एडमिनिस्ट्रेशन का काम है जो भी
काम है वो सब करेगा जो आपका सीएमडी भी कर
सीएमडी जो करता है उस वो उस वो सारे काम
प्लस एडिशनल बाकी बहुत सारे और
फंक्शनैलिटीज ये एग्जीक्यूट कर सकता है
ऑटोमेशन आप इसके थ्रू कर सकते हैं रिमोट
मैनेजमेंट भी आप इसके थ्रू कर सकते हैं।
दैट्स व्हाई इट्स वेरी डेंजरस। रिमोट
मैनेजमेंट के कारण, ऑटोमेशन के कारण ये
कुछ ज्यादा ही डेंजरस हो जाता है। क्योंकि
चीजें ऑटोमेट हो सकती है। अगर अटैकर का
कंट्रोल आ जाता है आपके पावर शेल के ऊपर
में तो वो ऑटोमेट करके अपने टैक्स को
ऑटोमेशन के थ्रू, रिमोट मैनेजमेंट के थ्रू
और भी ज्यादा इंपैक्टफुल बना सकते हैं। तो
पावर शेल एक जो है कमांड लाइन इंटरफ़ेस भी
है और साथ में एक स्क्रिप्टिंग लैंग्वेज
भी है जो Microsoft ने डेवलप कर दिया।
Microsoft ने ये चीज डेवलप की है Linux को
टेक ऑन करने के लिए क्योंकि देखो
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] Linux का जो
टर्मिनल होता है वो बहुत ही ज्यादा
पावरफुल होता है। हमेशा से पावरफुल था।
सीएमडी से काफी ज्यादा पावरफुल था। तो
Microsoft ने सोचा कि ऐसे तो काम नहीं
चलेगा। ऐसे तो लोग Linux के ऊपर मूव ऑन
करने जाएंगे ना। Linux एवरीथिंग Linx इज़
गिविंग एवरीथिंग ऑलरेडी। राइट? एक अच्छा
खासा मल्टीमीडिया एनवायरमेंट भी दे ही
देता है। अगर आप Fedura Ubent जैसी
प्लेटफार्म यूज़ करते हो तो आपका ओवरऑल
मतलब एवरेज मल्टीमीडिया काम चल जाता है।
इतना ज्यादा वो नहीं होता लाइक फ्रेंडली
नहीं होता बट स्टिल दैट्स इट। साथ में
बाकी सारी चीजें एडमिनिस्ट्रेशन का
सिक्योरिटी का
लाइक सर्वर मैनेजमेंट्स एवरीथिंग लाइक
एवरीथिंग इज़ वेरी-वेरी हैंडी। तो
Microsoft ने सोचा पावर शेल को ल्च करते
हैं। उसने पावर शेल को एक पावर पैक्ड टूल
की तरह ल्च किया एंड इसमें दुनिया भर की
फैसिलिटीज दुनिया भर की फंक्शनैलिटीज जो
है वो डाल दी है। ये पावर शेल आपको एक
छोटा सा कमांड लाइन इंटरफेस दिख रहा है।
बट इससे आप पूरी की पूरी सिस्टम को
कॉम्प्रोमाइज करके उसको पूरा ऑटोमेट करके
और ईच एंड एवरीथिंग यू कैन पावर शील्ड का
यूज़ बहुत ही ज्यादा बहुत ही ज्यादा डीप
एंड हाई लेवल पे भी किया जाता है। एंड इट
इज़ वन ऑफ़ द ग्रेटेस्ट टूल्स मतलब फॉर
हैकर्स। इतना मैं आपको बता सकता हूं। चलिए
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] पावर शील्ड
इज़ अ पावरफुल कमांड लाइन शेल एंड
स्क्रिप्टिंग लैंग्वेज इन Windows एंड इन
साइबर सिक्योरिटी इट सर्व्स बोथ एज़ अ
डिफेंडर्स मोस्ट वैल्यूुएबल एलआई एंड एज अ
प्रेफर्ड टूल फॉर एडवर्सरीज़। मतलब
डिफेंडर्स के लिए ये सबसे वैल्यूएबल एलआई
है। एलआई मतलब उसका दोस्त है डिफेंडर्स के
लिए कि भैया हां डिफेंडर्स के लिए भी
यूज़फुल है और हैकर्स के लिए भी ये बहुत ही
यूज़फुल टूल है। द बोथ ऑफ बोथ ऑफ़ देम आर
यूजिंग दिस पर्टिकुलर टूल्स। अब
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] फॉर
डिफेंडर्स ये क्या चीजें करता है? फॉर
अटैकर्स ये क्या चीजें कर सकता है? एंड
एंड हमारी सिक्योरिटी बेस्ट प्रैक्टिससेस
क्या हो सकती है? ये भी जानना बहुत जरूरी
है। देखो
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
फॉर डिफेंडर्स की अगर हम बात करें स्पेशली
अ
क्या खोल रहे हो?
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके। चलिए यहां पे कोई अ कोई पाकिस्तान का
कोई वाहियात इंसान बैठ आ चुका है तो उसको
हम हटा देते हैं। मुझे एक बात समझ नहीं
आती यार इन पाकिस्तान के सभी लोग तो नहीं
बट कुछ इतने
घटिया लोग होते हैं कि बेचारे हार हार के
भी फिर से आते हैं। समझ नहीं आता मुझे। एक
बार मतलब एक नहीं होता एक कहावत है बातों
के बातों के लातों के देव लातों के देव
बातों से नहीं मानते। वही चीज है ये
बेचारे। तो ये लातों के दानव हैं जो बातों
से नहीं मानते बेचारे। तो इनको हम हटा
देते हैं। इनको म्यूट कर देते हैं। पहले
मैं पहले मैंने बोर्ड लिया तब इनको हटाया।
इनका वो चीज किया। हटा दिया है। बताओ यार।
मतलब पाकिस्तान से आके यहां पर चिल्ला रहे
हैं। बताओ कितने पाकिस्तानी स्टूडेंट्स जो
हैं लर्नर्स जो हैं हमारी वीडियोस देख के
वहां सीखते हैं। उन्होंने सीखा है और
उन्होंने अपनी लाइफ में कुछ अच्छा अचीव
किया है। देयर आर थाउजेंड्स ऑफ़ पाकिस्तानी
लर्नर्स जो जिन्होंने डिफ्रॉनिक्स के
कंटेंट से बग बाउंट सीखी है। जिनको पहले $
$200 भी बाउंट नहीं लगती थी। उनको हजारों
डॉलर मतलब फोर डिजिट्स में भी बाउंट लगनी
शुरू हो गई। जस्ट बिकॉज़ ऑफ़ डेफ्रॉनिक्स
कंटेंट्स। उन्होंने स्टार्टिंग में उस चीज़
को एकनॉलेज करते थे। वह पोस्ट भी करते थे।
स्टार्टिंग में हमें टैग करते थे। बाद में
जब ये सब मैटर हुआ उसके बाद
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] उन्होंने बंद कर
दिया। नाउ दे आर डूइंग गुड इन देयर करियर।
एंड आई विश देम द बेस्ट फॉर देयर करियर।
मुझे काफी अच्छा लगता है। इफ दे हैव लर्न
समथिंग फ्रॉम डिफ्रॉनिक्स। बट जिस चीज से
जिससे आप सीखते हो जिससे आपने कुछ सीखा
उसी को आके आप यहां पे बोलोगे वो भी
इंडिया पाकिस्तान करोगे एक लर्निंग
प्लेटफार्म पे आके अभी ऐसे करके एंड मतलब
ये तो वही बात हुई जिस थाली में खाए उसी
में छेद कर लिया ये ये उनके आई थिंक उनका
शुरू से है तो इसमें ज्यादा टेंशन नहीं है
बट जस्ट इमेजिन कि मैं एक सोचता हूं कि एक
कहावत एक चीज होती है कि एक बात होती है
कि बाप को कभी सिखाना नहीं चाहिए बाप आपका
बाप ही होता है तो उसको क्यों सिखा रहे
हो? राइट
[खांसने की आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
या
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] सर
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] आई एम सिद्धार्थ
पाठक। यह मेरा दूसरा अकाउंट है एंड वो
ब्लॉक हो गया है बाय YouTube। एंड सर एक
बाहर का क्वेश्चन है। ऑ्ग कोड क्या होता
है डिफ्रॉनिक्स में? ऑर्ग कोड इज द बी डी
आई वी एफ वाई। बी डी आई वी एफ वाई
[खांसने की आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
हां वही बात है मुजमिल सर आई एम आल्सो
फ्रॉम पाकिस्तान एंड आई लव योर टीचिंग। सो
दैट्स द मेन थिंग आई सेड मुजम्मिल। मैंने
यही चीज बोली कि सारे पाकिस्तान के लोग
बुरे नहीं है। सब बहुत बढ़िया है। मेरे
काफी ऐसे स्टूडेंट्स हैं जो मुझसे काफी
इंटरेक्ट करते रहते हैं। मैसेज करते रहते
हैं। प्रज़ करते हैं। दे से थैंक यू एंड
एवरीथिंग। दे आर वेरी डाउन मतलब गुड। उनको
तो मैं बोलता ही नहीं हूं। बट कुछ ऐसे एक
उपद्रवी लोग हैं जो पूरे माहौल को खराब
करने की कोशिश करते हैं। बट उससे होना कुछ
नहीं है। माहौल को खराब करके भी कोई फायदा
नहीं है। कुछ नहीं है वो क्या होते हैं कि
हम हम क्या है
वो हाथी चले बाजार कुत्ते भौके हजारों
वाली बात है। राइट?
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
थैंक यू। जो लोग पाकिस्तान से हैं एंड जो
लोग बहुत ग्रेसफुली अच्छे से सीखते हैं
एंड दे डोंट डू यह सब इंडिया पाकिस्तान
तीन अरे यार इंसान हूं इंसान की तरह रहना
है। दैट्स इट दैट शुड बी देयर और कुछ भी
नहीं। सो आई वेलकम देम एंड दे आर गुड
पीपल। उनके लिए मुझे मेरे अंदर कोई हेट
नहीं है। मेरे को पाकिस्तान के लोगों के
लिए कभी हेट नहीं रहा। ना कभी नहीं था ना
है। बट वहां के कुछ ऐसे कैटेगरी के लोग
हैं जिनके लिए ऑटोमेटिकली हेट आ जाती है
और उन्होंने ही पाकिस्तान का बेड़ा गर्क
करके रखा है। पूरी पाकिस्तान की बैंड बजा
रखी है। क्योंकि उनके कारण बाकी पाकिस्तान
के लोगों के लिए ना लोगों में हेट आ जाती
है और लोग पाकिस्तान को गालियां देते हैं।
बस कुछ लोगों के कारण उसमें क्या-क्या है?
उनकी आर्मी शामिल है। उनके इन एजेंसीज
शामिल है। उनके पीएम शामिल है और कुछ लोग
शामिल है। पीपल ये सब लोगों के कारण
पाकिस्तान पूरी पाकिस्तान गाली सुनता है।
अब पता नहीं क्या क्या है उनका।
कोई बात नहीं।
थैंक यू। थैंक यू अब्दुल रहमान। थैंक यू
टू एव्री दोज़ लर्नर्स जो पाकिस्तान से हैं
और जो बहुत ग्रेसफुली पढ़ाई करते हैं सीखते
हैं उनको सीखने से मतलब उनको ये मतलब नहीं
है कि भाई इधर से आके इधर कर लो इंडिया
पाकिस्तान इधर से कर लो वो कर लो वो कर लो
उससे क्या हो जाएगा कुछ भी नहीं होना है
व्हाट नथिंग विल बी देयर आप सीखो ना
सीखोगे आई एम ऑलवेज विद यू आई एम ऑलवेज
देयर फॉर यू बस सिंपल सा हमने कई ऐसे
पाकिस्तानी स्टूडेंट्स को हमारी ट्रेनिंग
में बहुत ज्यादा डिस्काउंट क्योंकि हमारे
यहां का अगर कोई 20,000 का ट्रेनिंग है
वहां 4000 45000 कुछ पाकिस्तानी रुपए ऐसे
कुछ होता है मतलब बहुत ज्यादा इनफ्लेटेड
होता है। बहुत ज्यादा हो जाता है। हमने
बहुत डिस्काउंट दे देके उनको इनरोल कराया
था पहले इनरोलमेंट दी थी पहले। कई कुछ
पाकिस्तानी को हमने फ्री एक्सेस दे दिया
था। क्योंकि उन्होंने बोला था सर वी कैन
नॉट अफोर्ड मैं थोड़ा सा उस वैसे फैमिली
से बिलोंग करता हूं बैकग्राउंड से। तो
हमने दिया था। तो एटलीस्ट एक्सेप्ट दैट
ग्रेसफुली राइट? दैट्स इट। चलिए।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] एंड चलिए थैंक
यू।
ओके। सो यहां पे अब हम देखते हैं कि पावर
शेल का जो मेन मोटिव है फॉर डिफेंडर्स
क्या है? अटैकर्स क्या है? एंड हमारी कुछ
प्रैक्टिससेस क्या है? फॉर डिफेंडर्स ये
क्या होगा? जैसे कि मान लो अगर आप एक
एसओसी एनालिस्ट हैं या फिर आप एक इंसिडेंट
रेस्पोंडर है। देखो आज की टॉपिक छोटी होने
वाली है। थोड़ी आज की टॉपिक छोटी होगी।
थोड़ी कम क्लासेस की ड्यूरेशन भी कम होगी।
पिछले जो पिछला जो क्लास था वो कुछ ज्यादा
ही लंबा चल गया था क्योंकि उसमें ज्यादा
ही कुछ टॉपिक्स आ गए थे। आज की क्लास
थोड़ी छोटी होगी।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके सिद्धार्थ नो इशूज़ फॉर डिफेंडर्स
एसओसी एनालिस्ट्स के लिए इंसिडेंट
रिसोंडर्स के लिए क्या है देखिए ऑटोमेट्स
इंसिडेंट रिस्पांस एंड फॉरेंसिक कलेक्शन
अक्रॉस एंड पॉइंट्स तो इन लोगों के लिए
क्या करता है यह ऑटोमेट कर देता है
व्हाट इट डज़ यह ऑटोमेट कर देता है
इंसिडेंट रिस्पांस को और फॉरेंसिक कलेक्शन
के स्टेप्स को ऑटोमेट करने की क्षमता रखता
है आपका पावर शेल। हर चीज़ ऑटोमेट हो
जाएगी। तो मतलब रिस्पांस ऑटोमेशन के थ्रू
एंड फॉरेंसिक्स के लिए जो भी चीजें यूज़फुल
कक्शंस है, डेटा है उन सबका भी एक ऑटोमेशन
हो जाता है। तो दैट इज़ वेरी यूज़फुल।
पावर्स थ्रेट हंटिंग कॉन्फ़िगरेशन ऑडिट्स
एंड इंटीग्रेशन विद एसआईएम्स जैसे स्प्लंक
या Microsoft सेंटिनल हो गया या आपका कोई
भी लाइक एसआईएम्स जो होते हैं उन सब को
बेसिकली इंटीग्रेशन ऑटोमेशन इंटीग्रेशन
साथ में थ्रेट हंटिंग को पावर यही करता
है। कॉन्फ़िगरेशन ऑडिट्स को ये कर सकता है।
तो ये मल्टीपल चीजें जो है पावर शेल इसके
थ्रू की जा सकती है। इनेबल्स रैपिड
कंटेनमेंट एंड रेमडीएशन थ्रू स्क्रिप्टेड
प्लेबुक्स। अब इसमें आप स्क्रिप्ट भी चला
सकते हो क्योंकि यह एक स्क्रिप्टिंग
लैंग्वेज का भी पार्ट है। तो इसमें आप
स्क्रिप्ट्स रन कर सकते हो। तो
स्क्रिप्ट्स के थ्रू आप जो है कंटेनमेंट
ज़ोन बना सकते हो। कंटेनमेंट रूल सेट कर
सकते हो। रेमेडीएशन कर सकते हो। अलग-अलग
तरह के अटैक्स को मैप कर सकते हो। उनको
उनके लिए रेमडीएशन तैयार कर सकते हो।
कंटेनमेंट जो स्क्रिप्ट लिख सकते हो। एंड
दैट यू कैन यूज़ एज एन एन एन एन एन एन एन
एन एन एन एसओसी एल वन। ये थोड़ा सा एडवांस
पार्ट है। एसओसी एल1 के लिए ये काम नहीं
है। एसओसी एल1 इस तरह की स्क्रिप्ट्सिंग
स्क्रिप्टिंग और ये सब नहीं करते हैं। याद
रखिएगा एल1 का ये रोल नहीं है। ठीक है? जब
आप L2 L3 की तरफ आगे बढ़ेंगे तब आप अदर
स्क्रिप्टिंग्स एंड इन चीजों में थोड़ा सा
डीप घुसेंगे। अ फॉेंसिक्स इन्वेस्टिगेशंस
में डीप घुसेंगे एंड ये सब चीजें करेंगे।
तो L2 और L3 जैसे L1 है ना वो एकदम बिगिनर
रोल है। बेसिक स्टार्टिंग रोल है। तो L1
में थोड़ा काम आपको कम रहता है।
बेसिक-बेसिक्स काम होते हैं और एस्केलेशन
होता है। मेन आपका यही काम है। बट L2 और
L3 जैसे ही आपका प्रमोशन होता है तो आपके
काम धीरे-धीरे बढ़ जाते हैं। L3 द मोस्ट
इंगेजिंग रोल। यहां पे L3 का काफी काफी
कुछ रोल होता है। इंसिडेंट रिस्पॉन्डर का
काफी ज्यादा रोल होता है। ये चीज़ होती है।
हां। अब L2 और L3 यह ट्रेनिंग आपकी पूरी
L1 को कवर कर देता है। और मैंने सोचा भी
है प्लान किया है इन फ्यूचर में। मतलब अभी
तो मैं एग्जैक्ट नहीं बता पाऊंगा आप लोगों
को ना अभी कोई ऐसा कुछ प्लान है अभी तुरंत
ल्च करने का। बट इन फ्यूचर मैंने सोचा है
कि हम एसओसी L2
L2 जो So L2 एंड L3 इनकी ट्रेनिंग लाने की
वो ऑब्वियस सी बात है। पेड ट्रेनिंग होगी।
L2 एंड L3 की पेड ट्रेनिंग होगी। कि L1 तो
हम पूरा यहां पे कंप्लीट कर ही रहे हैं।
ऐसा मैं सोच रहा हूं एंड प्लान कर रहा हूं
क्योंकि हमारे पास कुछ मैसेजेस जो आए थे
कुछ स्टूडेंट्स के दे वेयर एसओसी
एस्पिरेंट्स दो एसओसी एंथोजियास्ट वो
एसओसी के लिए तैयारी कर रहे हैं ऑलरेडी
बहुत टाइम से इस ट्रेनिंग के स्टार्ट होने
से पहले से कर रहे हैं बट वो इस ट्रेनिंग
को भी देख रहे हैं क्योंकि उन्होंने कहा
कि सर हमारी जो आप जो पढ़ा रहे हो जिस
तरीके से हमें वो ज्यादा अच्छे से समझ में
आ रहा है। तो हम उसको एक अच्छे प्रॉपर वे
में क्लियर कर रहे हैं आपके वीडियोस के
थ्रू। तो उन्होंने बोला हमें कि सर आप L2
L1 तो आप यहां पे कंप्लीट कर दोगे। L2 और
L3 की पेड ट्रेनिंग लेकर आओ क्योंकि फ्री
ट्रेनिंग L2 L3 की पॉसिबल नहीं है। दैट
वुड टेक अ ह्यूज टाइम एंड उसके बाद भी
बहुत ज्यादा अच्छा रिस्पांस मिलता नहीं
है। तो L2 L3 की पेड ट्रेनिंग आएगी।
अफोर्डेबल रहेगा। उसके लिए आप बेफिक्र
रहिए। और जब वो ट्रेनिंग आएगी तो उसमें
आपको मैं एसओसी के प्रोफेशनल से वो
ट्रेनिंग दिलवाऊंगा। जैसे L2 और L3 का जो
प्रोफेशनल होगा ना जो ऑलरेडी इस में जॉब
कर रहा है जो ऑलरेडी इस पे वर्क कर रहा
है। ऑलरेडी एंटप्राइज में काम कर रहा है।
ऑलरेडी एमएसी में वर्क इस अलग-अलग
टेक्निक्स पे काम करते हैं। कैसे वो लोग
हैंडल करते हैं। वैसे बंदे से आपको
ट्रेनिंग दिलवाऊंगा। एंड वो ट्रेनिंग हम
सोच रहे हैं लाने की। आई वुड लाइक टू हैव
अ सजेशन फ्रॉम यू गाइस कि ऐसी ट्रेनिंग
आनी चाहिए। वो भी एक जॉब रेडी ट्रेनिंग
होगी। कंप्लीट जॉब रेडी। जैसे हमारी
वीएपीटी जॉब रेडी ट्रेनिंग है जो पेड
ट्रेनिंग जैसे हमारी ये एसओसी एल1 जॉब
रेडी ट्रेनिंग है वैसे ही L2 L3 के लिए हम
सोच रहे हैं जॉब रेडी ट्रेनिंग लाने के
लिए। हां उसमें हम L1 का बेसिक्स भी सारा
कवर कर देंगे ताकि आपको बिल्कुल
स्टार्टिंग से मिल जाए। लेकिन L2 और L3
पूरा कवर करेंगे। ये चीज़ हम सोच रहे हैं।
लाइक वी आर प्लानिंग। आई एम नॉट श्योर कि
अभी आएगा कि नहीं आएगा, कितना टाइम लगेगा
वो तो कुछ होगा तो बताएंगे। बट आई जस्ट
वांट टू गेट सजेशंस फ्रॉम यू ऑल। क्योंकि
आप लोग यहां पे काफी लोग अभी प्रेजेंट
हैं। तो मुझे एक बार बता दीजिए। आपका आपका
क्या सजेशन है कि वी शुड ब्रिंग L2 L3 पेड
ट्रेनिंग मतलब ऐसा कुछ कि ऐसा हो कि अगर
आप मतलब L1 वाले को L2 L3 पोजीशन आराम से
प्रमोशन हो जाए उस ट्रेनिंग के बाद आराम
से वो वो करें और डायरेक्ट कोई L2 L3 के
लिए जाना चाहता है तो डायरेक्ट वहां से
जॉब के लिए जा सकते हैं। ऐसा आई जस्ट वांट
टू आस्क। आपके जो भी सजेशंस है प्लीज बता
दीजिए। प्लीज लेट मी नो।
ब्रिंग L2 L3
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके
चलिए ठीक है। ओके। सो काफी लोग यस बोल रहे
हैं टू ब्रिंग। चलिए देखते हैं। आई एम आई
एम सीइंग इफ वी कैन ब्रिंग अह इन फ्यूचर
इन कमिंग टाइम।
ठीक है? वी विल सी।
अभी नहीं आएगी। अभी वह ट्रेनिंग नहीं
आएगी। वो ट्रेनिंग आएगी भी इस ट्रेनिंग के
एंड होने के बाद ही आएगी। इस ट्रेन जब मैं
इस एल1 को पूरी एंड कर दूंगा ना उसके बाद
ही वो ट्रेनिंग आएगी। उसके पहले नहीं
आएगी। इस बात के लिए बेफिक्र रहना है
आपको। आपको इस बात पे बेफिक्र रहना है कि
मैं इस ट्रेनिंग को इस एल1 ट्रेनिंग को जब
कंप्लीटली सेटिस्फेक्टरी जिससे मुझे
सेटिस्फैक्शन मिल जाएगा कि हां अब इसमें
कुछ भी नहीं बच गया। उसके बाद ही आपकी
सारी इंटरव्यू इंटरव्यू वाली क्लासेस करा
और आके आपको इंटरव्यू अह जॉब्स के लिए
अप्लाई करवा और आके उसके बाद ही वह
ट्रेनिंग आएगी। उसके पहले कभी नहीं आएगी।
टेंशन बिल्कुल नहीं लेना है। ठीक है?
एकदम बेफिक्र रहने का। [हंसी] उसके लिए
बेफिक्र रहिएगा।
ओके। अब तो ठीक है।
L1 ट्रेनिंग अगर इतनी डीप है तो L2 L3 आप
सोच भी नहीं सकते हैं। मैं इतना बोल रहा
हूं। मैं इतना आपको बता रहा हूं ना कि L2
और L3 की जो ट्रेनिंग जो भी ट्रेनिंग होगी
L1 की ही ये ट्रेनिंग आप जो करके अगर आप
जॉब के लिए जाएंगे ना इतनी नॉलेज वहां जो
ऑलरेडी काम करते होंगे ना जो कंपनीज़ में
एसओसी वाले उनको भी नहीं होगी। मैं गारंटी
बोल रहा हूं। उनको जितना काम होता होगा
उतना पता होगा। बस आपकी कॉनसेप्चुअल नॉलेज
इतनी ज्यादा होगी ना कि आप उनको लाइक आउट
परफॉर्म कर दोगे। सिंपल।
park साइबर फॉररेक्स एक्स
pक साइबर फॉरेक्स एक्स आपके लिए एक ही चीज
है एक ही बात बोलूंगा जस्ट शट योर माउथ और
चुपचाप निकल जा [हंसी]
ठीक है ओके सर आपके वीडियोस देख के एक टूल
भी बना रहा हूं क्या बात है ग्रूट ग्रेट
ग्रेट ग्रेट ग्रेट
क्या रिप्लाई करूं भाई? पहले जाके चावल तो
खरीद लो। ₹500 किलो है तुम्हारे यहां।
[खांसने की आवाज़]
फिर घर में चावल कैसे बनेगा? सर एसओसी
रिज्यूम रेडी करवा देते हैं। ठीक है। सब
हो जाएगा यार। हो जाएगा। टेंशन नहीं लेना
है। बाइनरी के ऊपर भी कोर्स लाइए ना सर।
पेड भी चलेगा। ठीक है। देखते हैं माइनरी
के ऊपर। ओके।
तो [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
फॉर डिफेंडर आपको समझ में आ गया होगा यहां
पे एसोसिए एनालिस्ट क्या किस तरीके से
एसोसिए एनालिस्ट के लिए इंसिडेंट
रेस्पोंडर के लिए ये यूज़फुल हो सकते हैं।
अब
फॉर अटैकर्स ये किस तरीके से हैं? रेड
टीमर्स या थ्रेट एक्टर्स के लिए इनेबल्स
फाइललेस मैलवेयर दैट एग्जीक्यूट्स इन
मेमोरी लिविंग फ्यूवर फॉरेंसिक
आर्टिफेक्ट। अब पावर शेल का यूज़ करके
अटैकर्स जो है ना फाइलेस मैलवेयर्स को
ट्रांसप्लांट कर सकते हैं आपके सिस्टम
में। फाइलेस मैलवेयर्स ऐसे मैलवेयर्स होते
हैं जो आपके सिस्टम के मेमोरी में रन होते
हैं। ठीक है? एंड कोई भी फाइल एज अ
रिसाइडुअल नहीं बचती है। कोई भी फाइल नहीं
बचेगी। मेमोरी में रन होगी और कोई फाइल
आपको सिस्टम पे नहीं दिखेगा। इट इज़ द
मोस्ट डेंजरस टाइप ऑफ़ अटैक। इसको हम
फाइललेस मैलवेयर अटैक बोलते हैं। तो इसका
इस तरह के भी अटैक अगर करने हो तो पावर
शेल का यूज़ किए जाते हैं अटैकर्स के
द्वारा। फैसिलिटेट्स लैटरल मूवमेंट लैटरल
मूवमेंट एंड प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन वाया
पावर शेल रिमोटिंग एंड लिविंग ऑफ
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] द लिविंग ऑफ द
लैंड टेक्निक्स जो लॉयल बेंस मैंने बताया
था लिविंग ऑफ द लै लिविंग ऑफ द लैंड
टेक्निक्स तो इस तरह के अटैक्स जो होते
हैं लाइक लैटरल मूवमेंट की बात हो
प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशंस की बात हो ये सारी
चीजें पावर शेल के थ्रू होती है क्योंकि
कमांड्स के थ्रू इनवोक हो रहा है तो
कमांड्स इनवोक करके एंड ये सारे कमांड्स
ये सारे काम को किया जा सकते हैं। द
नेक्स्ट इज़ द नेक्स्ट थिंग इज़ कि सपोर्ट्स
ऑफ़ फ़ेशन मतलब कि इनकोडिंग को मतलब
इनकोडिंग वगैरह करके इनकोडेड कमांड्स को
चलाना एंड कॉमन फ्रेमवर्क्स सच एज पावर
स्प्लिट एंड एंपायर। अब देखो यहां पे
सिंपल यहां पे कुछ स्पेलिंग मिस्टेक्स है।
इसको थोड़ा इग्नोर कीजिएगा। राइट? अ देयर
आर सम स्पेलिंग मिस्टेक्स। क्योंकि कुछ
यहां पे जो इमेजज़ होते हैं, मैं एआई
जनरेटेड यूज़ करता हूं। अ बाय क्रिएटेड बाय
एआई लाइक इंफोग्राफिक्स में से तो कुछ-कुछ
कहीं-कहीं स्पेलिंग मिस्टेक्स होते हैं।
तो प्लीज उनको थोड़ा इग्नोर कर दीजिएगा।
ठीक है? तो यहां पे फ्रेमवर्क को इसने
फ्रेमवर्क लिख दिया है। तो ये दिस इज़
फ्रेमवर्क। सो इसको इग्नोर कीजिए। तो
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
यहां पे ये इनकोडेड कमांड्स को भी यहां पे
यूज़ करके जो अटैकर्स होते हैं इनकोडेड
कमांड्स जिसको हम बोलते हैं ऑबस्टकेशन
बोलते हैं। तो इनकोडेड कमांड जैसे बेस 64
इनकोडिंग करके कमांड्स चला देना। एंड जो
अटैकर्स हैं ऐसे कमांड जब चलाते हैं तो
उनका मेन मोटिव होता है कि जो भी लाइक
किसी तरह की एंटीवायरस सॉल्यूशन है ईडीआर
एक्सडीआर टाइप की चीजें हैं उनसे बचना
उनसे सेफगार्ड करना अपने आपको एंड फिर जो
है मैलवेयर्स को प्लांट करना एग्जीक्यूट
करना तो इस तरह के काम भी एक अटैकर के लिए
जो है ये पावर शेल करता है। नाउ हमारे लिए
बेस्ट प्रैक्टिससेस अह सिक्योरिटी बेस्ट
प्रैक्टिससेस क्या हो सकती है? दैट इज़
इनेबल पावर शेल लॉगिंग। ठीक है? पावर शेल
का सबसे ज्यादा एडवांस एंड सबसे ज्यादा
यूज़फुल फीचर होता है पावर शेल लॉगिंग।
जिसमें कि स्क्रिप्ट ब्लॉक लॉगिंग,
मॉड्यूल लॉगिंग एंड ट्रांसक्रिप्शन ये
इंक्लूडेड होता है। सबसे ज्यादा इसमें
यूज़फुल होता है स्क्रिप्ट ब्लॉक लॉगिंग।
मतलब स्क्रिप्ट ब्लॉक लॉगिंग से क्या होता
है कि जो भी अगर कोई स्क्रिप्ट स्क्रिप्ट
से रिलेटेड कोई चीज अगर वहां पे
एग्जीक्यूट हो रही है पार्शियल के थ्रू तो
उसको लॉग किया जाता है। एंड वो लॉग में
आपको दिखेगा। इवेंट आईडी भी मैं बताऊंगा
उसका कौन सा इवेंट आईडी होता है। तो वो
लॉक जब होगी तो ये उस इवेंट आईडी के
अगेंस्ट जब आप देखेंगे तो आपको दिखेगा कि
अच्छा यहां पे कोई स्क्रिप्ट जो है वो
एग्जीक्यूट हुई है। कोई स्क्रिप्ट
एग्जीक्यूट हो रही है। सो इट माइट बी अ
डेंजरस स्क्रिप्ट एंड आप उसको स्टडी कर
सकते हैं। तो ये एक अच्छा प्रैक्टिस होता
है कि आप स्क्रिप्ट लॉगिंग जो है उसको
इनेबल करके रखिए। रेस्ट्रिक्ट पावर शेल
रिमोटिंग टू ऑथराइज़्ड एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर्स
एंड अप्लाई कंस्ट्रेंट लैंग्वेज मोड वेयर
फिजिबल। अब यहां पे क्या है कि आपको पावर
शेल का जो रिमोटिंग वाला फीचर है मतलब
रिमोट अह रिमोटली
कंट्रोल करना रिमोटली रिमोट कमांड्स चलाना
यह सिर्फ और सिर्फ एडमिन तक ही लिमिटेड
होना चाहिए। ये दिस शुड बी ऑलवेज दिस शुड
ऑलवेज बी नोटिस्ड कि जितनी भी
स्क्रिप्टिंग वाली चीजें हैं वो एडमिन तक
ही रेस्ट्रिक्टेड रहे। एडमिन के अलावा
उनको कोई भी ना चला पाए ताकि अगर अटैकर जो
है उसके पास अगर एडमिन प्रिविलज नहीं है
तो वो ऐसी रिमोट वाली कमांड्स ना चला पाए।
हां वो अलग बात है कि बाय चांस अगर अटैकर
ने किसी और तरीके से प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन
कर लिया है अपने आप को नॉर्मल यूजर से एक
प्रिविलेज्ड यूजर या फिर यूं कहें कि एक
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर बना लिया है तब तो आप उसको
नहीं रोक पाओगे क्योंकि एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर के
लिए ऑथराइज्ड है। तो बट अगर नहीं किया तो
एक हद तक आपका थोड़ा सिक्योर रहेगा। तो
प्रिविलज एस्क्लेशन रोकना बहुत जरूरी है।
किसी भी सिस्टम में देखो मैं आपको एक चीज
बताता हूं। दुनिया का कोई भी सिस्टम हो
कोई भी ठीक है? उसका सबसे अच्छा बेस्ट
सिक्योरिटी
अगर कोई अगर सिक्योरिटी मेजर है या
प्रैक्टिस है वो यह होता है कि जितने भी
काम इंपॉर्टेंट सेंसिटिव एंड जितने भी टॉप
लेवल के वर्क्स हैं उन सबको जितने भी
सिक्योरिटी रिलेटेड वर्क्स हैं उन सबको
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर तक लिमिट रखें।
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर तक ही लिमिट रखें। मतलब
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर ओनली कैन परफॉर्म दोज़
टास्क। ये चीज लिमिटेशन लगा दिया जाए। और
दूसरी चीज कि प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन को
रोकने की कोशिश की जाए ताकि सिस्टम में
कोई अटैकर घुस भी जाता है तो प्रिविलेज
एस्केलेट तो ना कर पाए कम से कम एक नॉर्मल
यूजर से अपने को एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर ना बनाए।
अगर यह दो चीजें सारे कंप्यूटर सर्वर्स
में अप्लाई कर दी जाती है तो उस कंप्यूटर
को बहुत सीवियर डैमेज करने से रोका जा
सकता है। सीवियरली डैमेज होने से वो
कंप्यूटर बच जाएगा। सीवियरली एक बड़ा अटैक
जो होने से बच सकता है। बट देयर आर आर इफ
देयर आर सिक्योरिटी देयर आर लूप होल्स। इफ
देयर आर सिक्योरिटी अ रूल्स जो कि बनाए
जाते हैं सिक्योरिटी को स्ट्रेंथ
स्ट्रेंथन करने के लिए तो देयर आर लूप
होल्स व्हिच मे ब्रेक दैट सिक्योरिटी। तो
वाइस वर्जन चलता रहता है। राइट? चलिए
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
मॉनिटर और एसआईएम फॉर अह लाइक किसी भी तरह
का एनोमेलिज़ एक्टिविटी जो होती है इनकोडेड
कमांड्स अनयूजुअल नेटवर्क कॉल्स एंड
अनएक्सेक्टेड मॉड्यूल्स। जैसे कोई अगर
इनकोडेड कमांड्स आपको कहीं पे दिख रहे
हैं। अनयूजुअल नेटवर्क कनेक्शंस दिख रहे
हैं या आपको कोई लाइक कोई ऐसी मॉड्यूल दिख
रही है जो आप एक्सपेक्ट नहीं कर रहे थे
यहां पे। तो ऐसी चीजों को मॉनिटर करते
रहना है एसआईएम के थ्रू कि भैया कोई इस
तरह की कोई चीज़ एक्टिविटी ना हो। अगर हो
तो तुरंत उस पे एक्शन लेना है। इनफोर्स
लिस्ट प्रिविलेज जैसा मैंने बताया आपको कि
सबसे लिस्ट प्रिविलेज वाली चीजें इनफोर्स
करके रखनी है। अप्लाई पैचेस पैचेस को
अप्लाई करना है टाइम टू टाइम एंड यूज़ एंड
पॉइंट प्रोटेक्शन। एंड पॉइंट प्रोटेक्शन
मतलब जैसे कि लाइक ईडीआर्स जैसी चीजें जो
है वो आपको यूज़ करनी है। सो दैट यू कैन
प्रोटेक्ट योर कंप्यूटर योर व्हाटएवर लाइक
अगर कोई मेमोरी रिलेटेड भी कोई अटैक्स
टाइप कुछ होते हैं तो उससे प्रोटेक्शन हो
सके। ये [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] एज अ
पावर शेल आपको समझनी थी। नाउ अगर
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] हम एसोसिएटी
रियलिटी की बात करें तो पावर शेल इज़
एक्सट्रीमली पावरफुल लेजिटमेट एंड
फ्रीक्वेंटली अब्यूज्ड बाय अटैकर्स।
अटैकर्स के द्वारा फ्रीक्वेंटली इसको
अब्यूज किया जाता है। अटैकर्स को पावर शेल
क्यों इतना पसंद है? तो भैया क्योंकि ये
कमांड्स एग्जीक्यूट कर सकते हैं इसके
थ्रू। पेलोड्स को डाउनलोड कर सकते हैं
कमांड्स के थ्रू। रजिस्ट्री को एक्सेस कर
सकते हैं इसके थ्रू। सर्विसेस को मॉडिफाई
कर सकते हैं। स्क्रिप्ट्स को मेमोरी में
एग्जीक्यूट कर सकते हैं। वही फाइललेस जो
मेलवेयर्स होते हैं मेमोरी एग्जीक्यूशन
वाले उसमें एंड जीयूआई रेस्ट्रिकशंस जितने
भी होते हैं उन सबको भी एक तरह से बाईपास
कर सकते हैं। सो अटैकर्स के लिए ये एक
गोल्ड माइन है आपका पावर शेल। इतना बस समझ
में आना है। ठीक है?
ठीक है? अब आगे की तरफ चलते हैं। पावर शेल
के आर्किटेक्चर को समझते हैं। ठीक है? दिस
इज़ द मोस्टेंट पार्ट यहां पे। इस पे थोड़ा
सा ध्यान दीजिएगा। पावर शेल के
आर्किटेक्चर को समझते हैं। देखिए पावर शेल
का आर्किटेक्चर देखने में आपको बहुत
कॉम्प्लेक्स दिख रहा होगा। ए यार ये क्या
है? ये क्या है? इतना ये सब क्या होचपच
है। बट इस पे आपको बिल्कुल भी ध्यान नहीं
देना है। यू डोंट हैव टू फोकस ऑन ये सब
क्या लिखा है? छोड़ दो। जो मैं बता रहा
हूं उसको समझना। बस सिंपल सा बस समझना।
कुछ इंपॉर्टेंट पार्ट होते हैं पावर शेल
के। कुछ पावर शेल जिसको हम पावर शेल
आर्किटेक्चर के थ्रू समझेंगे। एंड यह
पार्ट्स पावर शेल के लिए बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट
होते हैं। इस तरीके से पावर शेल आपकी काम
करती है। ठीक है? बस इतना समझना है। तो ये
जो इतना कॉम्प्लेक्स चीज है इसको मैं बहुत
इजी वे में समझाता हूं। समझ लीजिएगा। ठीक
है? क्योंकि ऐसे समझेंगे तो बहुत
कॉम्प्लेक्स लगेगा। आपको समझ में भी नहीं
आएगा। देखो पावर शेल में कुछ इंपॉर्टेंट
चीजें क्या-क्या होती है पहले वो जानते
हैं। सबसे पहला होता है होस्ट। एक होता है
होस्ट। मैं इसका कलर
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] थोड़ा सा
चेंज करता हूं। ब्लू कर देते हैं। यह होते
हैं होस्ट। पहला होता है होस्ट। ठीक है?
अब
यह होता है ये पहला होता है होस्ट
एप्लीकेशन। ठीक है? एक होता है होस्ट। ठीक
है? एक होती है पाइपलाइन। ठीक है? एक होता
है आपका रन स्पेस। ओके? एक होती है आपकी
पावर शेल प्रोवाइडर्स एंड एक होती है
सीएमडी लेट कमांड लेट सीएमडी लेट ये सारी
चीजें होती है ठीक है जो कि पावर शेल का
आर्किटेक्चर डिफाइन करती है तो एक होस्ट
एप्लीकेशन होता है ठीक है जिसको आप होस्ट
एप्लीकेशन बोलो होस्टिंग एप्लीकेशन बोलो
एक द होस्ट होता है द होस्ट इटसेल्फ एक
आपकी रन स्पेस इंटरफेस जो होती है वो होती
है। ठीक है? रन स्पेस जिसको बोलते हैं। एक
द पाइप लाइन आपका होता है। पाइपलाइन के
अंदर ही फिर सीएमडी लेट्स कमांड लेट्स जो
होते हैं सीएमडी लेट्स अलग-अलग कमांड्स वो
होते हैं। एक आपका पावर शेल प्रोवाइडर्स
होते हैं। बस इतने ही इसके मेन
आर्किटेक्चर के पार्ट हैं। तो आप देख
लीजिए यहां पे एक दो तीन चार पांच और एक
सीएमडी लेट भी ले लो छह जो कि बेसिकली
पाइपलाइन के अंदर ही फंक्शन करता है। तो
टोटल यहां पे मेन फाइव कॉमोनेंट्स हैं जो
मिलके आपके पूरे पावर शेल की आर्किटेक्चर
को डिफाइन करते हैं। बस अब समझते हैं
एक-एक करके। सबसे पहले बात करते हैं अ
होस्ट एप्लीकेशन। अब यहां पे मैं जो चीजें
आपको यहां पे जो चीज बता रहा हूं ना जिस
तरीके से चीजें ये सब समझा रहा हूं आपको
कोई भी आपको नहीं समझाएगा। इवन जब आप
एसओसी के लिए कहीं से प्रिपेयर भी करेंगे
ना तो बहुत कम जगह पे आपको ये डेप्थ
मिलेगा आपको इन चीजों को करने के लिए। एंड
ऑब्वियस सी बात है दिस इमेजज़ आर नॉट बाय
डिफ्रॉनिक्स।
ऑल क्रेडिट गोज़ टू द ओरिजिनल क्रिएटर एंड
जनरेटर ऑफ द इमेजज़। राइट? तो यहां पे जो
इतनी डेप्थ में आपको चीजें सिखाई जा रही
हैं। आई होप कि आप उन चीजों को सीरियसली
एंड सिंसियरली
समझते हैं, गेन करते हैं। एंड अगर मैं
एफर्ट डाल रहा हूं तो आप भी उसमें अपनी
एफर्ट लगा रहे हैं अपने साइड से। एंड आई
एम रियली ब्लेस्ड कि आप में से मैक्सिमम
लोग अगर ऐसा कर रहे हैं तो
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ठीक है क्या
सर ये कोल्ड कॉफी कैसे बनाया अरे भाई
तुम्हें इतने देर बाद कोल्ड कॉफी की याद आ
रही है वाह कोल्ड कॉफी बनाया सिंपल
ब्लेंडर देखो यह ब्लेंडर का जार है ठीक है
ब्लेंडर में सिंपल सा आपको क्या करना है
कॉफी डाल देनी है चार पांच सैच सैचेट जो
आती है छोटी-छोटी वाली ₹2 वाली या अगर 10
10 वाली है तो दो डाल दो। उसमें हल्की
शुगर डाल दो। जितनी मिठास आपको पीनी है कम
मीठा मैं कम मीठा पीता हूं थोड़ा। उसका
एकदम इतनी सी वाटर डाल दो। पानी थोड़ी सी
उसको ब्लेंडर में ब्लेंड कर दो। थिक पेस्ट
टाइप बन जाएगी थोड़ी। उसके ऊपर में चिल्ड
मिल्क डालो। एंड उसके बाद उसमें आइस डाल
दो। देन चॉकलेट सिरप ऊपर से गार्निश कर
दो। एंड जस्ट ऐसेसे घुमाओ एंड पियो। मस्त
मजा आ जाएगा तुम्हें।
ठीक है? सॉरी फॉर लेट। कोई बात नहीं। इट्स
फाइन। तो सबसे [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
पहले हम होस्ट एप्लीकेशन की बात करते हैं।
पावरशेल आर्किटेक्चर के अंदर में। होस्ट
एप्लीकेशन इज़ एनी एप्लीकेशन दैट लोड्स द
Windows पावरशेल इंजन। हां, पावरशेल एक
पावरशेल इंजन भी होता है इंटू इट्स
प्रोसेस एंड यूजज़ इट टू परफॉर्म ऑपरेशंस।
बस अ होस्ट एप्लीकेशन इज़ एनी एप्लीकेशन
दैट लोड्स द Windows पावर शेल इंजन।
Windows का जो Windows पावर शेल इंजन जो
होता है जिससे कि बेसिकली आपका पावर शेल
स्टार्ट होता है। जैसे कि पावर शेल जिसके
थ्रू लोड होता है उसको लोड करता है
पावरशेल इंजन को इंटू इट्स प्रोसेस।
क्योंकि आपको पता है हर प्रोग्राम जो होती
है ये हर प्रोग्राम एक प्रोसेस के थ्रू
चलती है। एक उसका प्रोसेस होता है जिसके
जिस जो एक मेमोरी यूनिट के अंदर में
एग्जीक्यूट होती है जिसका एक मेमोरी
एलोकेटेड होता है। ये सब मैंने पहले भी
बताया हुआ आपको कि एक हर प्रोसेस को एक
मेमोरी मिलती है और उसी मेमोरी के अंदर वो
प्रोसेस काम करता है। तो पावर सेल को भी
स्टार्ट करने के लिए कोई एक प्रोसेस होगी।
तो उस प्रोसेस में पावर सेल इंजन को यह
क्या करता है? लोड कर देता है ताकि यह
अपना पावर सेल वाला चीज हमारा स्टार्ट हो
जाए। दैट्स इट। कहानी यही है। तो, यह
हमारे होस्टिंग एप्लीकेशनेशंस होते हैं।
जैसे कि डिफॉल्ट आपका पावर शेल.exe हो
गया। यह आपका होस्टिंग एप्लीकेशन है। जैसे
पावर exc मतलब द थिंग इज़ मैं यहां पे दिखा
देता हूं आपको। T
कहां गए भाई?
यहां मैं पावर शेल की बात करूं। ये
Windows पावर शेल। राइट? अगर मैं इसकी
लोकेशन देखें तो यहां पे आपको पावर
शेल.exe वाली दिख जाएगी। ये स्टार्ट
हालांकि ये तो स्टार्ट मेनू वाला शॉर्टकट
आ गया है बट ठीक है फाइन मैं यहां से पावर
शेल लेट्स सी
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
हम स्टार्ट मेन्यू तो ये जो एग्जीक्यूटेबल
फाइल है बेसिकली power shellेल exc वो
आपका होस्टिंग एप्लीकेशन हो गया फॉर द
पावरेल दिस इज़ द होस्टिंग एप्लीकेशन हो
गया
[हंसी]
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़] कंसोल
एप्लीकेशनेशंस होते हैं Windows
एप्लीकेशनेशंस हो गया आपका वेब एप्लीकेशन
हो गया जो भी एप्लीकेशन जहां से पावर शेल
एग्जीक्यूट हो रही है वो होस्टिंग
एप्लीकेशन हो गया। उसके बाद आते हैं द
होस्ट पे। द होस्ट इज़ द इंटरफ़ेस बिटवीन द
कमांड्स एंड द पावर शेल इंजन। होस्ट एक
इंटरफ़ेस होता है। किसके बीच में? जो आपका
पावर शेल इंजन स्टार्ट हो रहा है और
कमांड्स के बीच में। बेसिकली जो कमांड आप
रन कर रहे हैं उसके बीच का एक इंटरफ़ेस है
होस्ट। बस यानी कि बेसिकली बोल सकते हैं
आपका जो होस्ट है वो जैसे कि मान लो आपका
जो मशीन है मान लो। ठीक है? जो आपका जो
आपका सॉफ्टवेयर है। तो होस्ट जो है वो
क्या है? वो एक इंटरफ़ेस है बिटवीन द
कमांड्स। जो आप कमांड्स रन करने वाले हैं
एंड द Windows पावर शेल इंजन जो पावर शेल
इंजन जो स्टार्ट हुआ उसके बीच यानी कि जो
आपका सॉफ्टवेयर है और जो कमांड्स है उनके
बीच का एक इंटरफ़ेस है आपका वो होस्ट है।
तो आप यहां देख सकते हैं होस्ट होस्ट का
ये इंटरफ़ेस हो गया यहां पे। अब इसके साथ
ही है रन स्पेस। पावर सेल रन स्पेस। अ रन
स्पेस इज द ऑपरेटिंग एनवायरमेंट फॉर द
कमांड्स इनवोक्ड बाय द होस्ट एप्लीकेशन।
अब होस्ट एप्लीकेशन पे यानी जैसे पावर शेल
का जो जो जैसे होस्ट एप्लीकेशन क्या है?
आप समझ में आ रहा है ना आपको? ये पावर शेल
है। ये मैंने ओपन किया। तो यही मेरा होस्ट
एप्लीकेशन है। दिस इज़ द होस्ट एप्लीकेशन।
जहां पे मैं कमांड्स को जैसे मैं मान लो अ
मैं यहां पे रन करता हूं। सॉरी मैं यहां
पे रन करता हूं गेट हेल्प गेट प्रोसेस।
ठीक है? तो ये जो मैंने कमांड रन किया तो
ये मेरा क्या है भैया? यही मेरा एप्लीकेशन
होस्टिंग एप्लीकेशन है जिसमें मैंने कमांड
को रन किया है। दैट्स इट। सो अ रन स्पेस
इज़ द ऑपरेटिंग एनवायरमेंट फॉर द कमांड्स
इनवोकड बाय द होस्ट एप्लीकेशन। होस्ट
एप्लीकेशन पे जो भी कमांड्स हम रन कर रहे
हैं वो कमांड जहां रन हो रहा है जो स्पेस
जहां पे वो जो एनवायरमेंट है उसी को हम रन
स्पेस बोलते हैं। सिंपल। अब पाइपलाइन की
बात करते हैं। पाइपलाइन इज द कंटेनर फॉर द
सीएमडी लेट्स एंड स्क्रिप्ट्स
दैट आर रन प्रोग्रामेटिकली बाय द होस्ट
एप्लीकेशन। अब होस्ट एप्लीकेशन जो कमांड्स
रन करती है, जो स्क्रिप्ट्स रन करती है,
उसका एक कंटेनर जिसके अंदर वो कमांड्स और
वो स्क्रिप्ट्स रन हो रहे हैं, उसी को
पाइपलाइन बोलते हैं। बस सिंपल सा फंडा है।
ये बहुत ईजी है। मतलब जिसमें आपका कमांड
जिस पर्टिकुलर मान लो एक छोटा सा कंटेनर
है उसी में आपका कमांड भी एग्जीक्यूट हो
रहा है। उसमें आपके स्क्रिप्ट सारे चल रहे
हैं। जो जो आप वहां पे टाइप कर रहे हो।
जैसे कमांड प्र्ट में सीएमडी में जो भी
कमा सीएमडी में आपने टाइप किया कमांड। मान
लो आपने डीआईआर कमांड डायरेक्टरी लिस्टिंग
के लिए टाइप कर दिया।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] ठीक है? या
होस्ट नेम कमांड, होस्ट का नाम डालने के
लिए या डेट कमांड ये सब चला दिया। तो वो
जो कमांड्स जहां रन हो रहे हैं ना वो एक
कंटेनर एक जो एक जो एरिया एक जो स्पेस में
रन हो रहे हैं उसी को हम क्या बोलते हैं?
पाइप लाइन बोलते हैं। पाइपलाइन के अंदर
में ही आपका जो है सीएमडी लेट्स और जितने
भी लाइक व्हाटएवर स्क्रिप्ट्स वगैरह होते
हैं वो सारी चीजें आती हैं। ठीक है? उसके
बाद आपके आते हैं पावर शेल प्रोवाइडर्स। अ
पावर शेल प्रोवाइडर्स जो हैं आर डॉट नेट
प्रोग्राम्स। ये डॉट नेट प्रोग्राम्स होते
हैं दैट अलाउज़ अस टू वर्क विद डेटा
स्टोर्स। सम बिल्ट इन प्रोवाइडर्स आर फाइल
सिस्टम प्रोवाइडर्स, सर्टिफिकेट
प्रोवाइडर्स ईटीसी। अब ये जो पावर शेल
प्रोवाइडर्स होते हैं, ये डॉट नेट
प्रोग्राम्स हैं। दैट अलाउज़ अस टू वर्क
विद डेटा स्टर्स। जो भी डेटा स्टर्ड जो भी
डेटा बेसिकली जो डेटा डेटा के साथ जो भी
काम करने के लिए आपका अलाउ कर रहा है जो
भी एक यूटिलिटी है उसको हम पावर शेल
प्रोवाइडर्स बोलते हैं। बस दैट्स इट जो कि
हमारे जितने भी पर्टिकुलर डेटा सोर्स या
डेटाज़ हैं उनके साथ ऑपरेट करने के लिए
हमें अलऊ करता है। ये यूटिलिटी को हम पावर
शेल प्रोवाइडर्स बोलते हैं। तो ये मेन चीज
थी। अब इसमें ये जो जितने भी चीजें मैंने
आपको बताई हैं जितने भी जितने भी मैंने
आपको बताई है वो चीजें उन चीजों में इसमें
सबसे इंपॉर्टेंट एक चीज है सीएमडी लेट
ये सीएमडी लेट यहां पे जो सीएमडी लेट यहां
पे आपको लिखा हुआ मिल रहा है कमांड लेट
बोल लो अभी के लिए सीएमडी लेट अब ये
सीएमडी लेट्स जो होते हैं यह ग्रुप ऑफ
कमांड्स का
ग्रुप ऑफ कमांड्स या कलेक्शन ऑफ कमांड्स
आप बोल सकते हैं फॉर पावर शेल जिसको आप
यूज़ करके एंड अदर वेरियस जो यूटिलिटी है
कमा पावर शेल की पावर शेल की जो एक्चुअल
पावर है उसको यूटिलाइज़ आप कर सकते हैं इन
कमांड्स के थ्रू जैसे कमांड प्र्प सीएमडी
के अलग-अलग कमांड्स होते हैं उसी तरीके से
सिमिलर आपका यहां पे क्या होता है सीएमडी
लेट होता है इसके लिए अब सीएमडी लेट के
बारे में हम जानेंगे तो बेसिकली सीएमडी
लेट इज़ द मोस्ट मोस्ट इंपोर्टेंट थिंग इन
होल दिस आर्किटेक्चर बाकी चीजें तो आपने
थ्योरेटिकली जान ली कि ये ये चीज़ होती है।
बट सीएमडी लेट के साथ आप इंटरेक्ट करते
हो। उसी के थ्रू अटैकर्स अटैक करते हैं।
उसी के थ्रू एसओसी उसको डिफेंड करते हैं।
हर चीज़ सीएमडी के थ्रू आपका होता है। अभी
मैं बताऊंगा क्यों इंपॉर्टेंट है। यू विल
बी अंडरस्टैंडिंग दिस। सो अभी तक मुझे
जितने लोग भी यहां पे अभी प्रेजेंट हैं।
54 ऑलमोस्ट आई जस्ट वांट टू नो। आई जस्ट
वांट टू नो हाउ मेनी ऑफ़ यू अंडरस्टुड। अभी
तक सबको सबको समझ में आया यहां तक की सारी
चीजें? प्लीज लेट मी नो।
आई वांट रिस्पांस फ्रॉम एवरीबॉडी। आर यू
अंडरस्टैंडिंग ये पावर सेल की आर्किटेक्चर
ईजीली आपको समझ में आई? बताइए मुझे।
प्लीज लेट मी नो।
ओके प्लीज [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
एवरीबडी
ओके
अंडरस्टुड ठीक है
एंड वी आर आल्सो गोइंग टू हिट अ
50 के सब्सक्राइबर्स वेरी सून चलिए तो सभी
को समझ में आ गई है
सॉलिड अंडरस्टैंड
ओके ठीक है सर आप समझाएंगे और समझ में
नहीं आएगा ऐसा ऐसा तो हो ही नहीं सकता
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
चलिए अच्छी बात है वेरी गुड ग्रेट
ओके [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] ठीक है ओके
गुड तो पावर शेल आर्किटेक्चर
दिस इज़ द मेन पावर शेल आर्किटेक्चर दैट वी
करेंटली गॉन थ्रू जिसमें कि आपका एक
होस्टिंग एप्लीकेशन होता है। होस्ट होता
है रन स्पेस पावर पावर शेल रन स्पेस होती
है। उसके अंदर फिर आपका पाइपलाइन होता है
उसके जो कि एक कंटेनर होता है सीएमडी
लेट्स का कमांड कमांड्स का एंड
स्क्रिप्ट्स का एंड पावर शेल प्रोवाइडर्स
होते हैं। ठीक है? दैट्स इट। ये
आर्किटेक्चर था पूरा। बाकी चीजों को भूल
जाइए। अब यहां पर आते हैं हम टू द बेसिक्स
जो या कॉमन पावर शेल के सीएमडी लेट्स हैं,
कमांड्स हैं, उनको हम थोड़ा देखते हैं।
ठीक है? ये कॉमन है। देयर आर अ लॉट ऑफ़
100्स ऑफ कमांड्स। बहुत सारे कमांड्स होते
हैं। आपको मैंने दिखाया था ना मैं अगर
पावर शेल ओपन करूं आईएससी। यहां पे मैं
आपको पावर शेल आए ओपन करता हूं। आपको समझ
में दिख जाएगा।
सो यू कैन सी हियर
स्क्रिप्ट्स
सॉरी सॉरी इसको क्लोज करो भाई
व्यू पे चलो अ
सो कमांड ऐड ऑन हां कमांड ऐड ऑन कमांड ऐड
ऑन पे जब आप आएंगे मैं इसको थोड़ा सा ज़ूम
सॉरी ज्यादा ही ज़ूम हो गया थोड़ा सा ज़ूम
करता हूं। ठीक है? अब यहां देखेंगे कि
यहां मॉड्यूल्स में देयर आर अ लॉट ऑफ
मॉड्यूल्स। यहां पे ऑल पे जब क्लिक करेंगे
मॉड्यूल्स पे तो आपको यहां पे देखने को
मिलेगा कि ऐप बैकग्राउंड टास्क के
मॉड्यूल्स, एप्स के बिट लॉockकर के
मॉड्यूल्स। देयर आर अ लॉट ऑफ़ मॉड्यूल्स
प्रेजेंट फॉर द पावर शेल। ठीक है? अब जैसे
मुझे अगर स्टोरेज से रिगार्डिंग कोई
मॉड्यूल चाहिए या मुझे चाहिए जैसे अ
लेट्स सी डिफेंडर से रिगार्डिंग। तो मैंने
डिफेंडर किया। तो डिफेंडर के रिगार्डिंग
जितने भी मॉड्यूल्स हैं यहां पे आपको मिल
जाएंगे। तो मैं यहां पे अगर ऑल पे क्लिक
कर दूं इफ ऑल तो ये देखो अल्फाबेटिकली ए
वाले इतने हैं। बी सी डी ई ये मैं
एक्सपेंड करता हूं। एफ जी से काफी ज्यादा
मॉड्यूल्स हैं। काफी ज्यादा जी से। यहां
देखो आप मैं स्क्रॉल कर रहा हूं। फिर एच
आई जे के एल एम एन मतलब बहुत सारे
मॉड्यूल्स जो हैं वो आपके पावर शेल के जो
होते हैं वो आपको यहां पे देखने को मिल
जाएंगे। ठीक है? यू विल गेट। अब इसमें से
जो भी आपको यूज़ करना है जैसे मुझे अगर मान
लो गेट से रिगार्डिंग कोई यूज़ करना है।
मैं यहां पे गेट लिख दे सॉरी मैं यहां पे
अ गेट लिख देता हूं। एंड यहां पे मैं डैश
देता हूं। तो गेट वाले जितने भी हैं वो
सारे यहां पे आ जाएंगे। तो मान लो यहां पे
मैं गेट अ
देखते हैं। ऊपर चलते हैं।
ओके। गेट प्रोसेस मैं कमांड एग्जीक्यूट
करता हूं। तो मैं गेट प्रोसेस यहां पे
एग्जीक्यूट यहां पे करना है मुझे। तो मैं
गेट प्रोसेस पे क्लिक करूंगा। तो यह क्या
करेगा? बेसिकली क्या करेगा? यह Microsoft
का पावर शेल मैनेजमेंट मॉड्यूल है फॉर गेट
प्रोसेस टू इंपोर्ट द Microsoft power शेल
मैनेजमेंट मॉड्यूल एंड इट्स सीएमडी
डिलेट्स इंक्लूडिंग गेट प्रोसेस क्लिक शो
डिटेल्स। ठीक है? तो आपको बेसिकली टू
इंपोर्ट द ये एंड इट्स सीएमडी डिले्स
इंक्लूडिंग क्लिक शो डिटेल्स। अब मैं अगर
शो डिटेल्स पे क्लिक करूंगा तो ये इसकी
बेसिकली अलग-अलग तरह की चीजें बताएगा।
मतलब थिंग यू कैन आल्सो डू। बट यहां पे
फिलहाल के लिए मैं यहां से अ
इसको इंसर्ट करता हूं यहां पे तो इंसर्ट
हो जाएगी ये गेट प्रोसेस एंड मैं इसको अगर
रन करता हूं तो यहीं से ये रन हो जाएगी।
तो बेसिकली आपको जितने भी प्रोसेससेस आपके
चल रहे हैं अभी फिलहाल के लिए वो
प्रोसेससेस आपको यहां पे दिखाएंगे। ये उसी
तरीके से है। लाइक आप सीएमडी जो ओपन करते
हो ना सीएमडी आई थिंक सीएमडी में
एक सेकंड।
हां। अभी अभी जो आपके सिस्टम में बेसिकली
जो प्रोसेससेस चल रहे हैं। बेसिकली
व्हाटएवर प्रोसेससेस इज़ ऑनगोइंग इन योर
सिस्टम। लाइक व्हाटएवर मैं यहां पे
प्रोसेस देख रहा था पीआईडी वगैरह का। तो
यहां पे आपको मिल रहा है। मुझे लगा था
यहां पे पीआईडी नहीं है। तो मैं सीएमडी के
थ्रू आपको दिखाता। बट यहां पे पीआईडी
ऑलरेडी है क्योंकि पीआईडी होने प्रोसेस के
बारे में डिटेल है तो पीआईडी ना हो ऐसा हो
ही नहीं सकता है। तो प्रोसेस आईडी यहां पे
सिंपल आईडी के नाम से तो आपके जितने भी
प्रोसेससेस अभी चल रहे हैं वो प्रोसेससेस
यहां पे आपको दिखा रहे हैं। लाइक व्हाटएवर
प्रोसेस उसका नाम प्रोसेस का नाम है यहां
पे आईडी है। सीपीयू का क्या यू कितना यूज़
केस वगैरह हो रहा है सारी डिटेल्स जो है
वो सारी यहां पे जो जो भी यहां पे आप देखो
यहां पे Chrome की प्रोसेस चल रही है। ये
सारी चीजें चल रहे हैं। ठीक है? हां
करेक्ट। सीएमडी में टास्क लिस्ट राइट राइट
राइट। सीएमडी का कमांड है टास्क लिस्ट।
उसमें भी आई थिंक सेम ही दिखाएगा। करेक्ट
टास्क लिस्ट। थैंक यू। ये टास्क लिस्ट है।
आई थिंक इसमें भी आईडी दिखाएगी आपको। आईडी
दिखाते बिना आईडी के तो नहीं होगा। हां।
यहां पे देखो यहां पे पीआईडी ये लिख रहे
हैं बेसिकली। एंड हियर ऑन दिस दिस इज़
सिंपल आईडी। राइट? तो इस तरीके से आपका जो
ये पूरा का पूरा प्रोसेस नेम है ये सिमिलर
ही है इसके। लेकिन यहां पे जो आपको कमांड
प्र्ट के साथ कमांड प्र्प के अलावा यहां
पे जब आप पावर शेल के अंदर काम कर रहे हैं
तो पावर शेल में आप इस पे और बहुत सारी
चीजें कर सकते हैं। लाइक देयर आर अ लॉट ऑफ़
अदर यूटिलिटीज़ दैट यू कैन इनवोक विथ दिस
पर्टिकुलर पावर शेल। एंड दैट्स व्हाई इट
इज़ मोर पावरफुल देन कमांड प्र्ट। कमांड
प्रॉम से ये काफी ज्यादा पावरफुल एक
यूटिलिटी है। बिलीव मी अगर आप इसको यूज़
करना जब आप पावर शेल से थोड़ा फमिलियर हो
जाओगे ना और आप इस पे अच्छा खासा हैंड्स
ऑन कर लोगे तो आपको बहुत ज्यादा मजा आएगा
पावर शेल में काम करने में। इट इज़ रियली
रियली इंटरेस्टिंग। तो इस तरीके से आप
इनवोक कर सकते हैं कमांड्स को। व्हाटएवर
कमांड यू कैन इनवोक। अरे यार यहां पे मैं
कमांड ऐड ऑन फिर से कर देता हूं यहां पे।
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़]
ओके। ओके। चलिए तो ये आपको समझ में आ गया।
अब यहां पे मैं क्या करता हूं? नीचे आ
जाता हूं। मैं यहां पे इसको मिनिमाइज अभी
फिलहाल कर लेते हैं। एंड वापस से स्लाइड्स
पे आ जाते हैं। तो यहां पे हम सीएमडी
लेट्स को जो है वो जान रहे थे। ठीक है?
सीएमडी लेट्स जो है उसको समझ रहे थे। तो
एक सीएमडी लेट में सबसे पहला आपका गेट
हेल्प आता है। गेट हेल्प से बेसिकली आप
सिंटेक्स क्या है इसका? गेट हेल्प। और जो
भी सीएमडी लेट के बारे में हेल्प चाहिए
आपको वो कमांड टाइप कर दीजिए। तो उसके
बारे में पूरी डिटेल और हेल्प जो है आपको
ये प्रोवाइड कर देता है। जैसे कि मतलब कि
जैसे हमने गेट प्रोसेस चलाया यहां पे।
राइट मैं नीचे की तरफ आ जाता हूं। एंड
यहां पे हम इसको क्लियर कर देते हैं। ठीक
है? एंड हियर आई एम गोइंग टू कर गेट
हेल्प। तो यहां पे ये थोड़ा सा वो भी देता
है। मतलब कि आपको एक ऑप्शन भी दे देगा कि
इसमें से कौन सा यूज़ करना है। तो इट इट्स
हेल्पफुल। उसके बाद आपको करना है गेट। अब
मान लो किसके बारे में आपको जाननी है तो
गेट प्रोसेस के बारे में जानना है तो गेट
प्रोसेस का अगर डिटेल चाहिए तो यह किया और
एंटर किया तो आपको गेट प्रोसेस के बारे
में पूरी ये डिटेल बताएगा कि इसका गेट
प्रोसेस नेम आपका सीएमडी का गेट प्रोसेस
इसका सिंटेक्स क्या है? बेसिकली अलग-अलग
सिंटेक्स जो सिंटेक्स हैं वो सारे बताएगा।
इसके एलियासिस क्या हैं? ये मैं पीएस यूज़
कर रहा था सीएमडी में बट पीएस यहां पे है।
एलियासिस मतलब आप इसके थ्रू भी इस कमांड
को चला सकते हो। या तो गेट प्रोसेस चला दो
या तो आप जीपीएस चलाओ या पीएस चलाओ। दोनों
में सेम आउटपुट मिलेगा। जैसे मैं अगर यहां
पे पीएस भी लिख के एंटर कर दूं तो वही
प्रोसेससेस की लिस्ट आएगी या जीपीएस भी
लिख के सर्च कर दूं यानी गेस्ट गेट अ वही
हो गया प्रोसेस हो गया तो भी आपको वही
वाली जो लिस्ट है वो आपको निकल के आएगी।
तो कहने का यहां पे सिंपल सा मतलब है कि
इसके जो एलियासेस हैं वो आपको हेल्प
करेंगे आपको शॉर्ट कोड्स में उस कमांड को
एग्जीक्यूट करने में। आप पूरा गेट प्रोसेस
मत लिखो। सीधा पीएस लिख दो या जीपीएस लिख
दो। एंड दैट्स इट। खत्म कहानी। यहीं पे
आपका कहानी जो है यहां पे आप इसको
एग्जीक्यूशन में ला सकते हो। एंड यू कैन
गेट द रिजल्ट्स एंड यू कैन सी द आउटपुट।
राइट? तो इसकी पूरी डिटेल्स आपको यहां पे
सिंपली बताता है। ठीक है? तो जैसे आपने
किया तो आप देख सकते हैं यहां पे। उसके
बाद रिमार्क्स यहां पे आएंगे। तो यहां पे
आएगा गेट हेल्प कैन नॉट फाइंड द हेल्प
फाइल्स फॉर दिस सीएम डिलीट ऑन दिस
कंप्यूटर। इट इज़ डिस्प्लेइंग ओनली
पार्शियल हेल्प। ठीक है? टू डाउनलोड एंड
इंस्टॉल हेल्प फाइल्स फॉर द मॉड्यूल। यहां
पे यूज़ इंक्लूडिंग दिस सीएम डिलीट यूज़
अपडेट हेल्प तो इससे अपडेट मतलब वो
डाउनलोड भी हो जाती है हेल्प फाइल जो भी
होगी डिटेल में तो ये आप हेल्प वाली कमांड
यूज़ कर सकते हो उसी तरीके से
बेसिकली अ
ओके अब गेट कमांड एक आपका सीएमडी है कमांड
है गेट कमांड उससे क्या होता है बेसिकली
गेट्स ऑल सीएमडी लेट्स फंक्शनंस एलियासेस
एंड स्क्रिप्ट्स तो जो भी आपके मतलब अ
जितने भी कमांड्स हैं, फंक्शनंस हैं,
एलियासेस हैं, स्क्रिप्ट है वो सब आप गेट
कमांड से कर सकते हो। गेट मेंबर से क्या
होगा? शोज़ द प्रॉपर्टीज एंड मेथड्स ऑफ़ एन
ऑब्जेक्ट। कोई भी एक ऑब्जेक्ट होगी लाइक
उसकी जो पूरी प्रॉपर्टीज है, मेथड्स है,
वो सारी चीजें यहां पे आपको ला के दे
देगा। गेट प्रोसेस से क्या होगा? गेट्स द
प्रोसेससेस रनिंग ऑन द सिस्टम। तो गेट
प्रोसेस उसके बाद हफन नेम मतलब नाम अगर
कोई देना चाहते हो दे दो। अदरवाइज़ सिंपल
गेट प्रोसेस भी लिख के एंटर कर दो। जैसे
हमने किया था। तो सारी प्रोसेससेस जो है
वो आपको यहां पे लाके दे देता है। गेट
सर्विस क्या करता है? गेट्स द सर्विसेस ऑन
द लोकल और रिमोट कंप्यूटर। तो जितने भी
सर्विज हैं वो सारी सर्विज जो है आपको
लाकर यहां पे दे देता है। व्हाटएवर सर्विस
जैसे मैं अगर ऑल्ट टैब करूं एंड हियर आई
एम आई एम जस्ट टाइपिंग गेट सर्विसेस
तो यहां पे जितने भी सर्विज आपके चल रहे
हैं रनिंग स्टॉप्ड या जो भी हैं वो सारी
यहां पे आपको देखने को मिल जाएंगी। फिर
सर्विस नेम भी आपको यहां पे दिख जाएगा। आई
थिंक सर्विस नेम के थ्रू भी आप यहां पे
चला सकते हो मल्टीपल थिंग्स। मैं एक बार
देख लेते हैं यहां पे गेट सर्विस एंड
सर्विस नेम के साथ। ओके
हम गेट सर्विस एंड ऐप इनफो। तो यहां पे ऐप
इनफो का स्पेसिफिक आपको यहां पे देखने को
मिल जाएगा। ओनली उसी के बारे में आपको
बताएगा। तो इस तरीके से सर्विस नेम के
थ्रू भी आप इसको एग्जीक्यूट ऐसे कर सकते
हैं। तो उसके बाद है आपका गेट डेट। तो
बेसिकली डिस्प्ले द फॉर्मेट एंड द करंट
डेट ऑफ द सिस्टम। जैसे गेट डेट जैसे डेट
कमांड होती थी ना वही चीज है यहां पे।
इसके लिए पावर सेल के लिए क्या होगा? गेट
डेट। तो ये चला दोगे, एंटर कर दोगे तो
यहां पे ये डेट यहां पे करके ये बता देगा।
अब इसकी हेल्प फाइल अगर हम देखें इसका कोई
एलियास है क्या? तो गेट हेल्प से गेट डेट
करेंगे। तो या एलियास नन है। कोई एलियास
नहीं है। गेट डेट ही आपको टाइप करना
पड़ेगा। तो आप गेट डेट के थ्रू डेट वगैरह
जो है एग्जैक्ट डेट एंड करंट टाइम
व्हाटएवर यू कैन जस्ट प्रिंट इट आउट।
राइट? तो इस तरीके से ये कमांड आपका रन
करता है। देन
हां ये प्रैक्टिस के ऊपर प्रैक्टिस के ऊपर
डिपेंड है। आपको थोड़ा सा याद ही करना
पड़ेगा। गेट लोके सेट लोकेशन। सो आप
चेंजेस द करंट लोकेशन। अ करंट वर्किंग
डायरेक्टरी का लोकेशन अब सेट जैसे आप चेंज
डायरेक्टरी करते थे ना सीडी कमांड लinक्स
में आप सीडी कमांड यूज़ करते हो डायरेक्टरी
को चेंज करने के लिए यहां पे सेट लोकेशन
आपको सीएमडी लेट्स कमांड्स यूज़ करने
पड़ेंगे फिर यहां पे गेट लोकेशन है यहां पे
डिस्प्लेस द करंट लोकेशन जो अभी करंट
वर्किंग डायरेक्टरी है वो आपको बता देगा
जैसे कि अ
गेट लोकेशन से मतलब वो मत समझ लेना कि वो
वो वाली लोकेशन आपकी ओरिजिनल लोकेशन
बताएगा वो नहीं है ये गेट लोकेशन से
प्रेजेंट वर्किंग डायरेक्टरी जो आपके
लinक्स में पीडब्ल्यूडी कमांड होता है ना
प्रेजेंट वर्किंग डायरेक्टरी यह वही बताता
है इसका कोई एलियास है क्या लेट्स सी गेट
हेल्प से पता चल जाएगा एलियास हां
पीडब्ल्यूडी इसमें काम कर रहा है बिल्कुल
एंड जीएल ये भी काम कर रहा है तो गेट
लोकेशन जीएल इसका शॉर्ट फॉर्म हो गया तो
अगर आप जीएल भी करोगे तो भी ये गेट लोकेशन
करके करंट देखो पीडब्ल्यूडी करोगे तो भी
यहां पे यानी ये देखो सीएमडी को मतलब ये
पावर सेल को बनाया ही गया था लinx को
दिमाग में रखते हुए लinx के साथ फ्यूज कर
दिया गया है बेसिक बेसिकली एक तरह का वही
सब सब सिस्टम है। एंड Linux के भी कमांड्स
को जो जनरिक कमांड्स हैं इस पे वर्क कर
जाए इसलिए भी बनाया गया था। तो ताकि
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] Windows
Linux का जो वो एक पूरा जो Linx हावी हो
रहा था पूरी Windows इकोसिस्टम पे उसको
थोड़ा सा कहीं ना कहीं सप्रेस किया जा सके।
दैट्स इट। तो ये एक चीज़ है। तो
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] यहां पे आप
PWD चलाओ या जीएल चलाओ या गेट लोकेशन चला
दो। दोनों बात सेम ही है। उसी
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] तरीके से
यहां पे गेट अ चाइल्ड अ अ गेट चाइल्ड आइटम
जो होता है बेसिकली अ इसमें क्या होता है?
गेट द फाइल्स एंड फोल्डर्स इन अ
स्पेसिफाइड लोकेशन। ठीक है? तो ये एक कोई
स्पेसिफाइड लोकेशन है। अ उस पे जो भी अ है
डेटा डायरेक्टरी वगैरह एक तरह से डीआईआर
वाला या एलएस वाला काम है ना वही काम ये
कर रहा है। सेट कंटेंट यहां पे क्या है?
क्रिएट्स अ न्यू फाइल और सेट्स द कंटेंट
ऑफ़ अ फाइल। मतलब नया फाइल बनाना हो तो सेट
कंटेंट। फिर गेट कंटेंट क्या है यहां पे?
डिस्प्लेस द कंटेंट ऑफ़ अ फाइल। अगर किसी
फाइल के कंटेंट को देखना है जैसे कि आप
बेसिकली लinक्स वगैरह जो है उसमें आप किसी
भी फाइल के कंटेंट को देखते हो। कैट वगैरह
कमांड यूज़ कर लिया या विमim एडिटर से भी
देख लेते हो। सेम वही चीज़ है यहां पे। ऐड
कंटेंट कंटेंट को ऐड करना है किसी फाइल
में। रिमूव करना है तो रिमूव आइटम। कॉपी
करना है तो कॉपी आइटम, मूव आइटम। ये सारे
जो है इसके कमांड्स हैं। देयर आर मल्टीपल
कमांड्स। मैंने आपको बताया। 100्स ऑफ़
कमांड्स हैं। आप सारे कमांड्स को याद नहीं
कर सकते हो। ना ही सारे कमांड आपको
प्रैक्टिकली याद होंगे भी। व्हाट यू हैव
टू डू कि जो भी आपके बेसिक कमांड्स होंगे
उन बेसिक कमांड्स को आपको सिंपली
प्रैक्टिस के थ्रू आपके दिमाग में वो सेट
हो जाएगी और आप उसको यूज़ करने के लिए यूज़
टू हो जाएंगे। मतलब रेगुलर बेसिस पे आप
उसको यूज़ करेंगे एंड आराम से यू विल बी
लाइक फमिलियर विद दैट। तो प्रैक्टिस के
ऊपर सब कुछ प्रैक्टिस के ऊपर डिपेंड करता
है। ठीक है? नथिंग एल्स। जितना प्रैक्टिस
करेंगे उतनी ज्यादा वो चीजें आपके दिमाग
में आएंगी एंड दैट विल बी यूज़फुल फॉर यू।
तो जितने यूज़फुल चीजें हैं वो ऑटोमेटिकली
जब आप एज अ एसओसी जाएंगे ना तो एज अ एसओसी
यूज़फुल [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
कमांड्स आप यूज़ करते-करते प्रैक्टिस आपकी
हो जाएगी एंड आप इस तरीके से पावर शेल में
उसको एग्जीक्यूट कर पाएंगे। ठीक है? ओके।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
अब
पावर शेल जो है वो सीएमडी से सीएमडी से
डिफरेंट क्यों है? कैसे है? सीएमडी एक
टेक्स्ट बेस्ड अ आपका
कमाल इंटरफेस है।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
यू आर वेलकम
लinक्स का राइट। पावर शेल जो है वो
ऑब्जेक्ट बेस्ड है। ऑब्जेक्ट के ऊपर
प्रोसेसिंग करते हैं। कमांड कमांड प्रॉम
जो है वो थोड़ा एक लिमिटेड इंटरफ़ेस है।
लिमिटेड चीजें आप उसमें कर सकते हो। बट
पावर शेल जो है वो बहुत ही पावरफुल है।
स्क्रिप्टिंग बेस्ड है। एंड यू कैन एज एन
एडमिन यू कैन डू एवरीथिंग। ये ओल्ड मॉडल
है। ये अभी नया मॉडल है। तो पावर शेल
एग्जीक्यूशन का अगर हम फ्लो देखें तो किस
तरीके से होता है? जैसे आपने गेट सर्विस
ये कमांड चलाया तो क्या होगा? कमांड आपने
एंटर किया पहले। देन पावर शेल इंजन जो है
उसको प्रोसेस करती है। देन कमांड जो है वो
एग्जीक्यूट होती है। एंड ऑब्जेक्ट जो है
आपको रिटर्न यानी ऑब्जेक्ट यहां पे कहने
का मतलब है जो भी आउटपुट आपको मिल रहा है
वो आपको रिटर्न में मिल जाता है। राइट जय
हिंद ब्रदर जय हिंद। जय हिंद निखिल। ये
आपके आउटपुट में मिल जाता है। दैट्स इट।
ठीक है? गॉट इट। पावर हाउस। बिल्कुल। अब
अटैकर्स यूज़ पावरफुल फॉर मैलवेयर डाउनलोड।
जैसे कि यह कमांड है इनवोक वेब रिक्वेस्ट।
इसके थ्रू मैलवेयर्स को डाउनलोड किया जा
सकता है। अगर पावर सेल कम कंट्रोल में आ
चुका है तो यह रिमोट कमांड यह रिमोट कमांड
में आ जाता है आपका। रिमोट कमांड का यूज़
किया जाएगा। इनवोक वेब रिक्वेस्ट टाइप एंड
उसके बाद एग्जीक्यूशन की जा सकती है। इन
मेमोरी एग्जीक्यूशन हो सकता है। अटैकर्स
जो हैं अलग-अलग तरह के अटैक्स यूज़ करते
हैं। जैसे मैलवेयर डाउनलोड कर इन मेमोरी
एग्जीक्यूशन जैसे कि फाइललेस मैलवेयर
जिसके बारे में मैंने पहले भी बताया हुआ
है कि कोई भी फाइल डिस्क पे रिटेन नहीं
होती है। मेमोरी में वो फाइल मैलवेयर जो
एग्जीक्यूट होती है, काम करती है एंड पता
नहीं चल पाता है। दैट इज़ वेरी डेंजरस।
क्रेडेंशियल डंपिंग। तो क्रेडेंशियल
डंपिंग में भी हेल्प करती है जिसमें कि
एलsस से इंटैक्ट कर सकते हैं पावर शेल के
थ्रू। अगर आप एडमिन है फिर तो बिल्कुल ही
छुट्टा आपको मिल जाता है इंटरेक्शन का एंड
यू कैन इंटैक्ट वि द एल्स एस एंड यू कैन
डू डैमेजेस टू द सिस्टम लैटरल मूवमेंट कर
सकते हैं। रिमोट कमांड एग्जीक्यूशन लैटरल
मूवमेंट करके रिमोट रिमोटली कमांड को
एग्जीक्यूट किया जा सकता है। पर्सिस्टेंस
जिसमें पर्सिस्टेंस वाला चीज़ भी आप कर
सकते हैं कि आप जब भी सिस्टम रिबूूट हो या
जब भी सिस्टम वापस से लॉगिन हो तो वापस से
जो मलवेयर है वह अपना काम शुरू कर दे। तो
रजिस्ट्रेशन रजिस्ट्री के अंदर मॉडिफिकेशन
की जा सकती है। स्टार्टअप प्रोग्राम और इन
सब को मॉडिफाई किया जा और शेड्यूल्ड टास्क
शेड्यूल्ड टास्क में मतलब कि एक टास्क को
शेड्यूल कर देना कि इट इस टाइम पे
पर्टिकुलर क्रॉन जैसे लinक्स में आपने
क्रोन जॉब पढ़ा होगा या सुना होगा उसी
तरीके से शेड्यूल टास्क है। एक टास्क को
पर्टिकुलर टाइम डेट के लिए शेड्यूल कर दो।
उस पे ऑटोमेटिकली वो रन करेगी। तो ये काम
भी इसके थ्रू पर्सिस्टेंस के लिए किया जा
सकता है। तो सीएम तो पावर शेल थोड़ा सा इस
इसलिए अटैकर्स के लिए काफी यूज़फुल भी होता
है और डेंजरस भी होता है। राइट?
अब
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
यहां पर आते हैं
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
Windows पावर लॉगिंग की जब बात करें तो
लॉगिंग का बहुत बड़ा रोल है पावर शेल के
अंदर में क्योंकि लॉगिंग जो होती है पावर
शेलel के अंदर में पावरशेल के
डिफरेंट-डिफरेंट लॉगिंग जो चीजें हैं वो
काफी इंपॉर्टेंट होती है। एंड दैट इज़ द
थिंग दैट वी आर एक्चुअली एज़ एन एसओसीएल वन
लुकिंग फॉर। सो जितने आपने इवेंट लॉगिंग
वाली जो क्लासेस करी थी उसमें मैंने इवेंट
अलग-अलग इवेंट आईडीज़ बताई थी। तो इवेंट
लॉगिन की चीज को यूज करते हुए आप देख सकते
हैं कि एक्चुअली किस तरह की चीजें जो है
वो किस तरह की आउटपुट या डेंजर आपके लिए
हो सकती है। तो जैसे इवेंट आईडी 413 अगर
कोई है तो मॉड्यूल लॉगिंग यहां पे होता
है। तो मॉड्यूल्स से रिगार्डिंग पावर शेल
के जो मॉड्यूल्स हैं उसके रिगार्डिंग
लॉगिंग यहां पे होगी। तो उससे आपको इनफेशन
मिल सकती है एज एसओसी वन 4104 वेरी
वेरीेंट स्क्रिप्ट ब्लॉक लॉगिंग। अब ये जो
स्क्रिप्ट ब्लॉक लॉगिंग है सबसे ज्यादाेंट
होता है एज एन एसओसी एल1 आपको इसके बारे
में थोड़ा स्टडी ज्यादा करना चाहिए कि
4104 जो इवेंट आईडी है उसमें स्क्रिप्ट
ब्लॉक लॉगिंग जो होता है कि अगर कोई
स्क्रिप्ट है उसको ब्लॉक कर रही है पावर
शेल उसकी लॉगिंग हुई है तो आपको चेक आउट
करना चाहिए कि क्या एग्जैक्टली वो
स्क्रिप्ट है क्यों ब्लॉक की जा रही है
क्या इसके अंदर में कौन सी कोड लिखी हुई
है क्या कोई मलेशियस कोड है क्या मलेशियस
स्क्रिप्ट है वो डेंजरस हो सकता है बाय द
अटैकर साइड 468 प्रोसेस क्रिएशन ये भी
बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट है कि कोई ऐसा ऐसा कोई
चाइल्ड प्रोसेस तो क्रिएट नहीं हुआ है जो
किसी मेन प्रोसेस की मिमिक कर रही हो,
उसकी कॉपी कर रही हो। बट एक्चुअली में वो
मलशियस प्रोसेस हो। तो ये भी आपको थोड़ा
सा एज एसोसियल वन ध्यान में रखना चाहिए।
ठीक है? बीइंग एन एसोसिएशनल वन। ठीक है?
हां। राइट? Linux में टर्मिनल है वैसे
Windows में पार्शियल है। तो इवेंट आईडी
4104 जो है बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट है। जैसे कि
मैंने बोला यह एक्चुअल स्क्रिप्ट कंटेंट
को लॉग करता है। जैसे कि अगर मान लो कोई
ऐसे कुछ इस तरीके से रिमोट कमांड चली है।
इनवोक वेब रिक्वेस्ट एंड यहां पे अटैकर ने
अपना खुद का वेबसाइट अपना खुद का
स्क्रिप्ट यहां से एग्जीक्यूट किया है।
पावरेल के स्क्रिप्ट है। पावर शेलel के
स्क्रिप्ट का एक्सटेंशन PS1 आपको देखने को
मिल जाएगा। ये जनरल जेरिक एक्सटेंशन होता
है। तो मान लो कोई वेबसाइट है ail.com
pलो.ps1 पावरशेल की स्क्रिप्ट है। उसको
किसी अटैकर ने कमा आपके पावर शेल के थ्रू
इनवोक वेब रिक्वेस्ट कमांड के थ्रू
एग्जीक्यूट किया है। तो यह अगर लॉग हुई है
इवेंट आईडी में तो उसको चेक आउट करना
चाहिए कि भैया यह कौन सी स्क्रिप्ट है जो
एक रिमोटली
रिमोट वेबसाइट से जो कि अपीयर्स टू बी
मलेशियस वहां से लॉग हो रही है। एंड इट
शुड बी सस्िशियस। एंड यह एसोसियल वन की
तौर पे आपको सस्पिशियस कैटेगरी में डाल के
और उस पे ओवर और ज्यादा इन्वेस्टिगेशन
करनी चाहिए। दैट्स इट। ठीक है? आई होप यू
आर अंडरस्टैंडिंग। यह समझ में आया यहां तक
आप लोगों को? जल्दी बता दीजिए भैया जी।
जल्दी सभी लोग बताइए एक बार। फटाफट बताइए।
फटाफट फटाफट बता दो भाई। फटाफट बता दो।
एवरीवन लेट अस नो
हम हम ओके गुड बहुत अच्छी बात है क्लियर
क्लियर
सर मैंने अपना फोन रिसेट किया है फिर
डेफ्रोनिक्स ऐप में भी नंबर एंड ईमेल आईडी
लॉग इन कर रहे हैं सर तो नहीं हो रहा है
प्लीज सो निखिल कुमार आप प्लीज हमारे जो
हेल्पलाइन नंबर है उस पर कांटेक्ट कर
लीजिए रिगार्डिंग दिस थिंग
मैंने वैसे तो बताया हुआ है। फिर बता देता
हूं। इफ्रोनिक्स वेबसाइट पर आप जाएंगे।
यहां हमारा नंबर है WhatsApp का। इस पर आप
मैसेज कर लीजिए। यह इशू के बारे में बता
दीजिए। आपका इशू रॉल्व कर दिया जाएगा। ठीक
है? इस नंबर पर कर लीजिए। ठीक है? थैंक
यू।
ओके।
गॉट इट? सभी को समझ में आ गया?
सर अभी तो सब एआई शिफ्ट हो रहे हैं। तो इस
कोर्स को करने के बाद कंपनी हायर करेगी ना
सर? बिल्कुल बिल्कुल एआई शिफ्ट हो रहा है
उससे अभी फिलहाल आपको टेंशन नहीं लेना।
पहले तो स्किल्स होनी चाहिए ना। तभी तो
एआई वाली चीजें भी गेन करोगे ना। एआई तो
यार एक एडिशनल लेयर है। अब एआई है इसका
मतलब ये थोड़ी ना कि आप बेसिक स्किल्स और
बेसिक कांसेप्ट्स बिल्कुल छोड़ दो। ऐसा
नहीं है यार। यू नीड टू अंडरस्टैंड द
कॉन्सेप्ट्स प्लस एआई। देन दैट वुड वर्क।
दैट्स इट। यू हैव टू वर्क ऑन दैट
पर्टिकुलर। यू हैव टू वर्क ऑन बोथ। नॉट
जस्ट सिंगल अह अह एआई एंड एआई। राइट? तो
बस ऐसा ऐसा ही करना है आपको। चलिए
अब पावर शेल इनकोडेड कमांड्स की हम बात
करते हैं। पावर शेल इनकोडेड कमांड्स का
मतलब है यहां पे कि जैसे मान लो पावर
शेलॉx एग्जीक्यूट हुआ। इनकोडेड कमांड के
थ्रू कोई मान लो बेस 64 इनकोडेड कमांड
एग्जीक्यूट हो रही है। तो अटैकर्स इसका
यूज़ करते हैं इनकोडेड कमांड कमांड्स का ऑफ
फस्टेशंस के लिए डिटेक्शन को अवॉयड करने
के मतलब किसी एडीआर, एक्सडीआर, एंटीवायरस
सॉल्यूशन से डिटेक्शन अवॉइड करने के लिए
इनकोडेड कमांड का यूज़ किया जाता है। कमांड
को इनकोड कर दिया जाता है। किसी भी
इनकोडिंग को ले लो उससे इंकोड करके चलाया
जाता है ताकि एंटीवायरसेस एडीआर एसडीआर को
वो डिटेक्शन में थोड़ी कम मतलब कम
डिटेक्शन लेस डिटेक्शन हो। तो एज अ एसओसी
आपको उसको डिकोड करना होता है एंड उसके
बिहेवियर को एनालाइज़ करना होता है। एज
एसओसी एल1 कि हां भैया इसको देखें पहले
कौन सा इनकोडेड है इनकोडिंग्स है उसको फिर
डिटेक्ट मतलब डिकोड किया जाए। कोशिश कीजिए
डिकोड हो जाए एंड देन उसको एनालाइज़ कीजिए।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] अब एज अ
Windows पावर शेल में रेड फ्लैग्स में
क्या-क्या चीज़ हो सकती है? अगर इनकोडेड
कमांड्स है तो वो रेड फ्लैग होनी चाहिए
आपके लिए। आपको एज एन एसओसी एल1 अगर कहीं
पे भी आपको इनकोडेड कमांड दिख रही है तो
आप समझिए यहां पे कुछ गड़बड़ हो सकती है।
स्ट्रिंग्स की डाउनलोडिंग हो रही है लाइक
डाउनलोड स्ट्रिंग्स तो वहां पे थोड़ी सी
गड़बड़ी हो सकती है। बेस 64 टाइप इनकोडिंग
वगैरह देखें तो उसमें और ज्यादा डेंजरस हो
सकती है। बाय पॉलिसी बाईपास जैसी कोई चीज
अगर हो रही है इनवोक हो रही है एग्जीक्यूट
हो रही है वो भी आपके लिए सस्िशियस होनी
चाहिए। कोई हिडन विंडो वगैरह ओपन हो रही
है तो वो भी आपके लिए सस्िशियस होनी
चाहिए। जैसे कि मान लो पार्शियल पे
एग्जीक्यूट एग्जीक्यूशन पॉलिसी बाईपास इस
तरीके कुछ अगर आपको दिख रहा है तो यह
सस्िशियस है क्योंकि कोई भी बाईपास
रिलेटेड चीज अगर इवेंट एग्जीक्यूट हो रही
है तो दैट शुड फॉल अंडर हाईली सस्िशियस
एक्टिविटी एंड एज एन एसोसिएट एल1 आपको
सस्िशियस एक्टिविटी को पहचानना आना चाहिए।
आप एक अच्छे एल1 एनालिस्ट बन सकते हैं।
अगर आपको यह पता है कि जो एक्टिविटी हो
रही है उसमें कौन सा सस्िशियस हो सकता है
एंड उसमें जितना ज्यादा अच्छी आपको आपकी
वो होगी ना कि उसको पकड़ने की क्षमता उतनी
ज्यादा आप अच्छे एक एनालिस्ट कहलाएंगे।
दैट्स इट। ओके?
लॉग्स की बात करें तो हम यहां पे रियल
एसोसिएट सिनेरियो की बात करते हैं। लॉग
आपको कुछ इस तरीके का लॉग देखने को मिल
सकता है। मान लो यहां पे 468
आपको प्रोसेस आपको देखने को मिल सकता है
यहां पे जिसमें पैरेंट winword.exc
प्रोसेस है। चाइल्ड प्रोसेस power.ex या
winword यानी वर्ड microsoft word के
प्रोसेस में उसका चाइल्ड प्रोसेस
powerl.exec कैसे स्टार्ट हो सकता है?
ठीक? 4104 यहां पे प्रोसेस एंड यहां पे
इनवोक वेब रिक्वेस्ट टेबल.com सेम वही चीज़
जो है कमांड एक रिमोट कमांड को एग्जीक्यूट
किया जा रहा है। कुछ इस तरह का लॉक देखने
को मिल रहा है। तो इसका मतलब है कि यहां
पे फिशिंग हुई है। फिशिंग के बाद पावर सेल
की एग्जीक्यूशन हुई है। फिर मैलवेयर को
डाउनलोड किया जा रहा है। यह एज एसओसी आपका
कंक्लूजन होना चाहिए। अगर आप ऐसे ही लॉग्स
देखें तो आप समझिए यहां पे फिशिंग है।
पावर सेल एग्जीक्यूशन हो रही है। मैलवेयर
डाउनलोड करने की कोशिश की जा रही है।
दैट्स द मेन लॉग इज़ सेइंग। सो इस तरह के
लॉग्स हो तो बी अटेंटिव। दैट्स इट।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ठीक है?
नेक्स्ट
यह एज अ एसओसी सिनेरियो था जहां पर आप एज
अ एसोसिएल वन इस तरीके की चीजों को
परफॉर्म करते हैं। तो ये पूरी की पूरी बस
आज की सेशन इस पूरी पावर शेल के ऊपर में
थी। यहीं पे आपकी सेशन को समाप्त किया
जाता है। आज के सेशन बस इतना ही था। मैंने
पहले ही बोला था कि आज का सेशन थोड़ा छोटा
होने वाला है। बिकॉज़ पावर शेल को हम कवर
कर रहे थे। इसके बाद सेशन में हम एक्टिव
डायरेक्टरी को कवर करेंगे। एक्टिव
डायरेक्टरी का भी बेसिक आपको पता होना
चाहिए। बहुत ज्यादा डीप नहीं जाना है
क्योंकि एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी अपने आप में एक
पूरा कंप्लीट कोर्स हो सकता है। ये
कंप्लीट बहुत डिटेल चीज़ है। तो हम बा
एसओसी के अलाइंड जो चीजें हमें जानकारी
चाहिए एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी के बारे में वो
जानेंगे। उसको हम पढ़ेंगे। उसको हम
समझेंगे। राइट? तो ये चीजें हम नेक्स्ट
क्लास में एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी को कवर करने
वाले हैं। ये क्लासेस ये जो पावर शेल है
यहां पे हमने कंप्लीट कर लिया। आई होप
आपको पावर शेल के बारे में पता चल गया
होगा। पावर शेल क्या होता है? पावर शेल
कैसे काम करता है? पावर शेल में
आर्किटेक्चर क्या होते हैं? एज एन एसओसी
किस तरीके से आप पावर शेल को देखते हैं।
आर्किटेक्चर के सारे डिटेल्स मैंने आपको
बताएं। उसके अलग-अलग कमांड्स बताए हैं।
देयर आर 100्स ऑफ़ कमांड्स। आई वुड लाइक टू
आस्क यू एवरीबॉडी टू प्रैक्टिस दोज़
कमांड्स पावर शेल के अंदर में। आप उनमें
से एसओसी के आपको क्या काम करना है?
Google पे जाके एसओसी रिलेटेड या एसओसी से
अ लाइक एसओसी के लिए यूज़फुल जो भी कमांड्स
हैं उन सबको फाइंड करके उस पे प्रैक्टिस
करनी है पावर शेल के अंदर में एंड देखना
है क्या-क्या उनके आउटपुट आ रहे हैं
क्या-क्या चीजें आ रहे हैं। एवरीथिंग तो
यू विल बी गेटिंग द आउटपुट एंड उस पे
प्रैक्टिस करनी है। साथ में नोट्स बनाने
हैं। मैंने पहले ही बोला था कि नोट्स बना
के मैंने आपको बार-बार बोलता हूं ये काम
आप सबको करना है। बट पता नहीं कितने लोग
करते हैं। हालांकि देखो बहुत लोग करते हैं
बट स्टिल आई एम सेइंग नोट्स बनाने हैं।
Lindin पे आपको आपकी प्रोफाइल नहीं है तो
नया प्रोफाइल बना लो। बिल्कुल फ्री ऑफ
कॉस्ट होता है। Lindin पे जाके आपको उन
नोट्स के जो की टॉपिक्स हैं, की पॉइंट्स
हैं उनको आपको Lindin पे पोस्ट करना है।
कुछ ऐसे लोगों की तरह जैसे मैं अभी
नोटिफिकेशन पे चलता हूं।
आप देख सकते हैं। मैं आपको दिखा देता हूं।
लाइक बहुत लोग पोस्ट करते हैं। एंड
एंड इट्स गुड दैट दे आर पोस्टिंग। ऐसे ही
आपको करना है। ये क्या हो गया भाई? ओपन हो
जाए यार। क्या दिक्कत है?
ओके। सो देयर आर सम इशज़ इन Lindin
नोटिफिकेशंस।
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़][अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
हां, काफी लोग बनाते हैं नोट्स। पता है
मुझे की पॉइंट्स। हमको Linu पोस्ट करके
हमें टैग कर देना है। दैट्स इट। और कुछ भी
नहीं है।
चलो मैं यहां पे डेफ़ोनिक्स वाले पे करता
हूं। इसमें शायद ओपन हो जाए।
या फिर Lindin का ही कुछ इशू होगा। ओके।
देयर आर सम इशूज़ इन Lindin आई थिंक सो।
ओके। ओके Lindin का कुछ इशू है। Lindin के
सर्वर का या Lindin वेबसाइट के तरफ से कुछ
इशूज़ है। तो इसको छोड़ देते हैं अभी
फिलहाल के लिए। लेकिन Lindin पे जाके आप
पोस्ट कीजिएगा और वहां पे हमें टैग कर
दीजिएगा। डिफ्रॉनिक्स को की पॉइंट्स को
टैग करके पोस्ट कर दीजिएगा। ठीक है? ये
कैन नॉट बी रीच्ड आ रहा है। इसका मतलब कुछ
इशू है। अभी शायद सही हो गया। या अभी आई
थिंक इट्स गुड। ठीक है? तो मैं आपको दिखा
देता हूं नोटिफिकेशन के थ्रू जो जैसे
पोस्ट करते हैं लोग।
जैसे यहां पर इन्होंने पोस्ट किया है।
ठीक है?
ठीक है? जैसे अभी यहां पर चलो एक पोस्ट आ
ही गई अभी आ गई। डे 19 का इन्होंने पोस्ट
किया है। तो आप देख सकते हैं इन्होंने डे
19 डीप ड्राइव इनू विंडोज आर्किटेक्चर
रजिस्ट्री ये सारी चीजें करी है। उसके बाद
पूरी यहां पे डिस्क्रिप्शन है की टेक अवेज़
वगैरह जो है वो सारी चीजें पॉइंट वाइज़ करा
है। एंड यहां पे डिटेल्स और भी मेंशन करे
हैं। एंड यहां पे स्क्रीनशॉट्स या जो भी
है वीडियोस के बहुत सारे लोग वीडियोस के
लिंक्स भी डालते हैं। आप वीडियोस के लिंक
डाल दीजिएगा ताकि और लोगों को पता चले।
एंड यहां पे इन्होंने हमें टैग भी कर दिया
है। मुझे भी टैग कर दिया, डिफरेंश को भी
टैग किया। इस तरीके से आपको नोट पोस्ट
करने हैं। एंड यू हैव एंड हैव टू टैग अस।
ठीक है? टैग कर दीजिएगा। दैट्स इट। ये
करने के आपका क्या होगा कि आप इसी बहाने
की पॉइंट्स भी नोट कर लेंगे। आपकी रिवाइज
भी हो जाएगी। और जब भी आप कोई वीडियो
देखें तो उसके कमेंट उसमें कमेंट्स जरूर
कर दीजिएगा। जितने भी वीडियोस हैं, जस्ट
पुट डाउन द कमेंट्स ऑन दोज़ वीडियोस। दैट्स
इट। ठीक है? बस
कमेंट्स कर दीजिएगा 100 प्लस कमेंट्स हर
वीडियो में। लास्ट क्लास में भी डे 20 में
भी 100 प्लस कमेंट्स अभी नहीं हुए हैं। आई
वुड रिक्वेस्ट एवरीबॉडी टू पुट डाउन 100
कमेंट्स प्लस इसमें भी कर दीजिएगा। देन
नेक्स्ट क्लास आपकी आ ही जाएगी। एंड दैट्स
इट। कोई बात नहीं।
ओके पीडीएफ आपको मिल जाएगी। ग्रुप में ही
रहिए आप निखिल। आपको पीडीएफ वहां पे सारी
मिल जाएगी या उसी नंबर पे कांटेक्ट कर
लीजिए। यू विल गेट ऑल द पीडीएफ। ठीक है?
सो बस आज के क्लास के लिए इतना ही गाइस।
थैंक यू वेरी मच। टॉप फैंस की लिस्ट मैं
यहां पे आपको दिखा देता हूं सभी लोगों को।
सो हियर इज़ द टॉप फैंस लिस्ट। मैं नाम
इसलिए नहीं बोल रहा हूं क्योंकि नाम बहुत
ज्यादा 50 लगभग होते हैं तो थोड़ा मुश्किल
होता है सारा नाम बोलने में। तो यह टॉप
फैंस की लिस्ट है। एंड वी थैंक देम टू बी
कंटिन्यूड टू बी एक्टिव इन द लाइव सेशंस
एंड दे आर गोइंग टू डू ग्रेट इन कमिंग
टाइम। आई एम श्योर। तो ये पूरी लिस्ट है।
आप देख सकते हैं यहां पे। दिस इज द लिस्ट।
ओके चलिए।
ओके गाइस। सो बस दैट्स इट गाइस। अ
कौन सा ग्रुप का लिंक? डिस्क्रिप्शन में
आपको सारे ग्रुप का लिंक मिल जाएगा। जो भी
ग्रुप्स का लिंक या जो भी लिंक होंगे ना
वो डिस्क्रिप्शन में आपको इस वीडियो के भी
या किसी भी वीडियो के मिल जाएगा। ठीक है?
एज ऑलवेज आपके क्लास में मजा आएगा। ग्रेट।
थैंक यू फॉर सर। ग्रेट सेशन यू आर वेलकम।
यू आर वेलकम। सो बस गाइस जाइए आप लोग सभी
अब डिनर वगैरह करिए। जिनको कोल्ड कॉफी
बनना है पीना है मैंने रेसिपी बता दी है
बना के कोल्ड कॉफी पी लीजिए
लास्ट का थोड़ा बचा था उसको भी मैंने खत्म
कर दिया
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़][अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
या चलिए सो थैंक यू वेरी मच गाइस फॉर
जॉइनिंग द सेशन आज की सेशन थोड़ी जल्दी
एंड करते हैं दो घंटे भी नहीं कर रहे हैं
थोड़ी जल्दी एंड कर देंगे क्योंकि क्लास
आज की हो चुकी है मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट क्लास
में गाइस फिर एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी वाली
पार्ट के साथ आई होप कि यू विल एंजॉय दैट
सेशन आल्सो जाते-जाते लाइक ठोक देना
वीडियो को शेयर करना करना उनके साथ जिनको
इसकी जरूरत है इन क्लासेस को हर जगह फैला
दो वीडियोस को बस यही आपकी हेल्प हो जाएगी
हमारे लिए जस्ट स्प्रेड आउट द वीडियोस एंड
सब्सक्राइब कर लेना अगर नहीं करा हो तो
बेल आइकॉन ठोक देना ताकि नोटिफिकेशन मिलती
रहे आपको क्योंकि नोटिफिकेशन नहीं मिलेगी
तो आपको पता नहीं चलेगा क्या चीजें कब आ
रही है राइट थैंक यू वेरी मच ठोक दिया
लाइक धन्यवाद यहां पे अच्छी बात है यहां
पे ऑलमोस्ट 100 लाइक करके चले जाना 93 हुए
हैं 100 करके चले जाओ ठीक है थैंक यू वेरी
मच गाइस मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट क्लास में एंड
टिल देन टाटा बाय-ब गुड नाइट शुभ शुभ
रात्रि टू एवरीबॉडी।